[Musique]
il
je
pour être
m
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
et
il
non
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
com
quoi
[Musique]
il
et
[Musique]
je
m
en vain
et
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
et
et bonjour à tous pour cette nouvelle
journée
salut à toi
bon écoute ça va bien ça va bien je suis
en forme
way you can't j'ai vu quatre ce matin et
de la visite il y avait baky qui était
la mdl et où donc
donc voilà passer une bonne matinée
créer créer créer du cri à fond c'est
bien mais ouais du coup du coup avec
alpha échec ils décommandent dédicacé
des échiquiers des livres des trucs et
ouais bah du coup c'est les autres
châteaux 6 et voilà b aujourd'hui on a
des belles affiches pas
[Musique]
ouais on verra mais c'est de faire est
donc ouais c'est koné roue contre roue
iphone donc super match et causé nul
contre contre sara alors là pour le coup
c'est du déjà vu et normalement c'est
c'est la marche trop haute pour ce soir
à ces demi finales mais peut-être qu'une
fois en lorraine sur les environs
[Musique]
en fait faut je passe tu es sur aube et
est un truc tu vois où le volume quand
on doit tuer deux plus ou moins dans le
jaune et c'est bien donc sûr je pars
l'histoire de parler comme ça tu auras
tu as fait des tests et je sais pas moi
moi moi j'entends normalement mais je
suis pas sur le live vk quoi il est très
très difficile
quel mal y lit que ça va prêcher
pas-de-calais mais lille est très
indulgent j'en sais rien mais en fait
et lloris je dis ouais pas de 2100 voire
sans risque d'ailleurs il ya une seule
russe cette fois en demie mais peut-être
qui trollent en fait un simple les
autres disent que ça va
comment entendre plus voilà sert à rien
je fais la potiche je serai peut-être
commencer du côté des écouteurs avec
acquis sont qui vont pas du tout quoi
très possible pense investir bonté ask
folle ou autre chose tu vois un peu
moins faim c'est audible ça va non mais
je je comprends qu'ils aient un intrus
qu'un belgique a dit dans son son et
fantastique son est parfait et on les
studios et je vais encore baissé fab
là c'est bon là je vais crier
mais non non j'ai pas j'ai pas une
petite voix en plus c'est juste que je
sais pas là exceptionnellement salaires
d'être moins fort que d'habitude mais je
n'ai pas une petite voix alors juste
comme ça je vous met les les joueuses
pour que moi je vois le pseudo de qui je
dois folle ou quoi puisqu'elles ont fui
ou en suit ou highway bon dieu va mieux
pour mon frère on a le choix d'être
embauchés salut pata points au pied
voilà bah pour moi c'est bon je suis en
train de suivre un choix qui a les mêmes
masters je sais pas quoi lâcher des jeux
doivent finir donc c'est pour ça qu'on
soit ouais mais en fait je sais pas on
s'en fout on voit les deux événements en
même temps on sait ce qui est prévu à
l'heure à l'autre préfet il peut être le
problème c'est que du coup y'a salman
williams qui est à l'antenne de thiès
comme anormal et que du coup voilà ses
chroniqueurs une journée de foot de
ligue 1 tu as les matchs doivent
consommateurs et là attention il ya le
real qui joue non on va tous les cas les
parents commencent à l'heure il ya deux
tournants même parler d'eux tombe à 15
ans le temps c'est même pas le problème
c'est donc c'est ça le problème c'est
que je pense que ça doit pas être unie
du coup j'ai pas de nouvelles d'eux
et des pivots sport balasy fait un blitz
pour l'instant comme ça ça me le truc
regarde jouer
[Musique]
ok j'ai fait un blessé j'ai fait un bis
tu commandes tout jeu des fleuves je
vais faire un blitz bazire ce parti et
moi je joue un bon jour il faut qu'on
voit quand même pas cieux allez je fais
un blitz
c'est parti donc là vous allez voir on
vient là pour soit du vrai niveau quoi
pas fait pas je fais du 3 évitera
plaisir jusque tueuse qui te disent déjà
plusieurs spas donne des pièces pour les
jets
m'est avis pas aller aux différents 8
avril un blessé vent en glisse parce
qu'il va y avoir la partie commence très
bientôt
ouais mais ça c'est plus intéressant
parce qu'on fait que débite son but ont
choisi pointage score nous y aider au
genre je prend en otage la chaîne qu'est
ce que me faire quoi voilà j'ai l'air
d'être pas trop mal j'ai pris cet air de
fukushima dit je vais faire rager faire
b 6 x 6 quoi ça leur message à pouvoir
bailly n'a pas vu du monde dégage voilà
qui n'a plus rien fait si l'aja jean
violas position la joueuse française qui
défend son adversaire et met ses pas et
s'est pas frémi school à se faire une
glace et french school fais des footings
atamna son sueur celle ci précieuse
entreprises de plus l'autre ouais bah ça
à très bientôt commencer et partie où là
il ya un quart à l'emprise il voit pas
les crans par mois je vous recommande la
partie l aveugle
londres est en train de défoncer
[Musique]
lors de sa ville gilbert transition suis
désolé les gars c'est pas vu c'était un
show dallas et nos penderies match
battez jtac tysabri match entamait 3 et
rendu plus fort c'était pas mal ay
regarder juste ah non ça commence vatin
fier à un ballet sais pas je verrai
yeahs non je sens pas du tout sérieux
mais bon on est obligé de faire en fait
allez donc où il fane avec les bonbons
de koné roux première demi finale du
jour
ouais et où ils font l ajout est fou
c'est 4 donc pour éviter la petrov
adverse
ah oui c'est vrai que les indiens maison
indiens chinois de sa fille braff d'acta
à payer un peu plus un petrov c'est
l'ouverture des pays peuvent les gars a
on va essayer chauffage déjà normalement
je l'avais est là elle est repartie
normalement je l'avais j'avais mon pied
en cap xavi bon mais est ce que tu veux
j'avais mon pays parce que on l'a jamais
vu pour le coup ah bah oui on veut
l'avoir avoir une piscine maman quoi
elle a vraiment la tête typique de la
moyenne
si c'est une maman mais oui fans en tête
de profs et puissent être des pros pas
forcément donc
pourtant c'est pas si fort la paix
trouve messi y performent à petrov quoi
basse et solide un fait mais ouais c'est
fort caruana derrière la beaucoup joué
avec des résultats probants genre en
2018 non mais c'est que la trouver des
idées surtout en fait même s'ils
recueillent les c3 qui avait l'air assez
sûr
avec son cahier 17 et ouais ouais non
mais cameron a été hyper pas d'heure je
sais pas pour qui l'arrivée puisque je
suis personne lui a causé de problème
dessus d'être juste cela m arrive de
voir autre chose mais les trois noms
mais en fait déjà je me demandais
pourquoi les années 2000 c'était un peu
passé de mode parce que en fait krainik
la jouer à fond tu allais shirov guelph
on t'avait à nantes
tous les mecs sérieux qui jouait sa est
en fait juste chez pai bon la bernoise
est tellement forte qu'en fait ils ont
plutôt faire le pèlerinage
qu'est ce que c'est d'être encore plus
simple avec la berlinale mais je crois
pas qu'ils se soucient parti et donc
voilà donc faussée 4 c'est une manière
d'éviter est juste déconné roux le maire
local ans et si ses lames il pioncer 6
pour prendre le centre avec des cinq
donc cette manière plus ambitieuse jeu
avec les noirs elle a fait ce plan avec
à 5 à 4 qui est sympa qui prend de
l'espace et la bouche suit pas ce serait
utile mais des fois tu as la tour qui
peut coulisser part à six par à 5 par
quelque part c'est surtout utile quand
les blancs font reprendre et s'éprend
d'un jeu à dire puisque là dans cette
structure là bon mais ça peut arriver
il y avait une partie de golf en je
crois il avait battu un mec fort de
karuïa qui nous quoi avec son plein donc
voilà où en fait il ya peut-être pas je
la structure symétrique qui va reprendre
le cadre je pensais que kid c3 on va
faire comme elle veut en fait hein mais
pourquoi pas avec l'idée peut-être un
jour dans men d'amarrage 5 un truc comme
ça fait quoi
ouais ouais non ça joue sajou mal fou à
2 kg 5e damage 5 c'est un beau trio
piasco si on peut le mettre sur pied
quand même pourquoi pas des trois c'est
vrai que ça aille avec 7
en fait ceci à 2 x 2 kg 5
donc il ya un problème c'est beaucoup
plus grave de perdre à vii le dîner des
3 way mais là du coup quatre conscience
pour les blancs
ce qu'on fait des progrès mais on espère
peut-être chasse et de cavaliers ou en
reprend du cavalier kelly centrale qui
sera pas mal placé ma foi les deux sont
possibles des projets h6 peut-être on
peut faire des 1 h 4 des coups comme ça
pour des bouffes lecavalier on va te
matin
du coup on en reprendrait pas mais bien
les perspectives d'un tacle en tout cas
du côté blanc alors là il ya encore des
gens qui sont arrivés dans la réunion du
coup ça m'a encore décalé lac à ma part
j'avais préparé avant le stream et ouais
faut pour la préparer en fait il ya
bibeau peau qui est très heureux du
trikini appuieront barrette j'ai tu vas
battre plein de mecs comme toi moi
j'étais petit je baptême des 10700 en
rien un trait dans la française sont les
ventes ont foulé 5-fu décès des clés key
pour le 5 et surprendre ou 4 2 5l foulée
5 en l'air et son prend 17 up poker par
l'arrière et a gagné 5 c'est pas mon
truc à moi c'est juste sur quelle
variante tout un port de vendres davance
par exemple de la française imerys en
fait en allemand les blancs vont jamais
trop mettre à fond en bessin et parce
qu'il n'a rien à faire là bas mais t'as
plein de joueurs qui débutent un peu eux
ou qui disent ah tiens je me développe
cela s'appelle rio que tu développes un
foutu pour un cavalier tu dis que c'est
bien mais pas trop donc voilà et chez
plus il est vert et qui est papa foin
qu'il demanderait donc ils s'activent à
jouer pour mulhouse mais c'est pas où je
joue pas je crois que je reste à clichy
donc
donc voilà pour l'instant je vous pour
clichy a pas de raisons je change
damages snack choix au regard vers la
cam ouais c'est que tu te fais quoi
mais c'est normal c'est à gaza ils font
tous tu disparais petit à petit donc
vous avez gagné la paire de fou soit fou
prend ses obligés on attaque et sept ont
attaqué cette possible de faire autre
chose et du coup il fan avait tenté de
la travailler au corps
macquart de 15,9
moi je suis passée rennes avec les morts
en fait voilà petrov c'est de la merde
en fait je mens mais voilà non c'est pas
mal pour les enfants ça reste solide un
la pression n'est pas sans portes sont
ouvertes
lui qui avait il va trouver des petites
cases eelv à gigoter il ya venir verser
5 qui promettait de revenir vers eux 6
mais l'un dans l'autre avec les blancs
on prétend à faire un petit truc qu'on
n'est pas un des principes id insipide
nancy by l'insipidité du coup pas dans
ce pays était ici c'est hyper dur à dire
insipidité insipide sur ce il sauf que
genre t'as plein plein de syllabes d'un
coup et en fait j'ai tendance à aller
bouffer ouais c'est pas moi facile mais
tu peux faire des exercices
un chasseur sachant chasser sans son
chien c'est un bon club
c'est chiant à la dir weh et de chutes
ce choc et bienvenue chez s'acheva par
exemple c'est très difficile
du coup collés ou un peu en sueur ainsi
les bons peut faire grand raclée blanc
peuvent te faire flamber quatre
suivantes eu avec ta dam faut faire
gaffe travail au coeur du caire c'est le
french 29
ouais voilà bigot qui les chaussettes de
l'archiduchesse sont elles sèchent arcis
archi seul à lci fermé vous vous écrivez
d'un chat mais nous on doit parler quoi
abbas est ce que ce sera plus dur mais
bon après on peut faire des concours de
dactylo bon du coup leur parti ans et 7
et non échus et blanc à voir est ce que
scary clair quand même fou bécade
provoque ces cinq elle repart avec son
fouquet un temps mais c'est un peu la
casse des 5
enfin je suis pas sûr qu'on soit trop
obligé grand roque ça m'a l'air pas
qu'on petit rock non plus d'ailleurs
possible voilà pas si cons elle a fait
grand cas ok elle envoie du coup pas mal
à prendre le contrôle de la colonne d
une fois que l'or a touché à son food et
de la tour pourra passer éventuellement
jarre en d3 et partir sur les droits il
ya des petites idées à droite à gauche
et c'est pas trop agréable pour les
mains voila j'ai réussi à nous mettre
ma maman à l'âge aux indiens naples en
sueur pris ce prix se passe si mal
peut-être poussé trois pour prat a que 5
qui aura accueilli 17 pour l'instant qui
tient mais c'est difficile pour un noir
je pense que ces trois j'aime bien parce
que cas et décès at on fait un truc
comme f3 on double les tours mais mieux
le cahier en fait il y va de fixer en 17
déc et objets ils vont perdre 5
donc en fait c'est pas top non plus au
regard des teintes et horrible 20
secondes seulement ouais c'est dur c'est
la seconde entre les 8 40
bon après on sait que les jeux sont
jamais à l'abri d'une déconnexion ou
d'un mot slip on a connu tout ça donc on
sait jamais on fera celle avantages des
partis comme ça sur internet c'est que
jusqu'au bout at il jamais à l'abri de
rien comme tessa tout peut tourner sur
un coup on en a pendant pour nos
émotions vous ces trois incertains quand
même fou ces trois cas l'idée c'est la
doublette comme tu as dis moi j'aime
bien ça vous qui êtes bel avantage pour
les blancs ouais donc les poussettes
rock etc et ça j'y avais pensé je sens
que je vais faire tous ces trois avants
avec le damage 5 pour fort ce qui est
des 7 et pas qu'ils aient été si ce qui
est des 4 mais bon j'imagine que
l'univers
même des trois hockey qu'elle sait si
cette froide m17 j'imagine vous donne
des six rd7 je ferai plus naturellement
mais dans ces cas pas mal tout ça qui
est des quatre on prend deux fois est du
coup assurée en double et ses petites
tours tranquillou ok ça s'avère bien
salaire mais j'aurais préféré quand même
campagne était en 17 ans nettement ouais
ça vite les autres après le drame c'est
que tu as quand même à quatre en l'air
c'est quand même très très bien pour les
associations et la bouffe est un pion
bon alors s'active un petit peu mais
attention au temps attention au temps ça
se pourrait devenir critique pour nous
aussi
je préfère donc il y avait des saints
que cette menace qui était un peu
chiante tu prennes après le cavalier
elle est ce que c'est si claire à yakin
un gros poids en moins mais pourquoi
est-il si groupes armés oui c'est bien
refaire être quatre à un moment d'être à
quatre je préviens qu'à bloquer pas se
prendre dessins extraits chiant voilà la
fin du stage à aa
et voilà certains généraux qui se bat à
fond qui a repris son pion deux mois
mais en fait tout peut se passer
cinq secondes à la pendule ubs qui soit
je pense ça va être un match de qualité
n'ont normalement oui ces deux bonnes
choses koné rôle joue pas mal rapide en
plus mais la même favorite en cette fin
de partie cognon vu la dynamique de la
ronde de la partie ouais et la valeur
juste section cynophile et laisse à m
elle va perdre c'est sûr est-ce qu'on va
aller pour les nuls n'ont pas raison sur
quoi vous mettre la tête sous l'eau le
faire du bbc chaque jour un droit une
dame en l'air bon là il a même fait des
prises
bon bah que we fall ans sur des combos
mines étaient restées très bien elle a
fait le meilleur parti mais dès que ça
s'est accéléré elle a été commandée
passé j'ai vieilli mais du coup c'est un
peu inquiétant pour elle parce que
contre katia dans la fois qu'on a
commenté ensemble et perdait 3 0 quand
même en partie de cinq minutes mais en
une minute avaient tous en retard mais
s'il allait te fais de même dominé un
enjeu très rapide je sais pas où est ce
qu'elle va mettre ses points donc tu
t'inquiètes pour ou quoi très inquiet
très inquiet points faibles et jouent
trop maintenant est peut-être trop forte
ça c'est une règle vis à vis exactement
c'est théorique et si comme la voilà
donc je commençais juste ans et
spécialités de mathieu et quoi dire bah
c'est un truc très solide quoi c'est un
mélange de gambie dame et de newzoo
c'est à dire qu'on met le pion au centre
le fond mais quatre ans puisqu'ils foule
cavaliers donc on joue pour un contrôle
central juste on l'a déjà dit à haute
voix cassée celui-ci est pas top top en
ajournant avoir alors redéployés et une
idée peut-être pour les noirs se
prononcer 4 à mener le front des 6es
faire aux cinq peut-être dire hermes a
sonné une assez classique en fait madame
g si ça peut être un coup aussi je sais
pas et donc à voir mais normalement oui
enfin elle connaît bien ça aussi c'est
une ouverture qu'elle joue depuis
longtemps mais des joueurs chinois la
joue beaucoup
c'est un peu là petrov sur des quatre
quelques pas j'avais déjà
ouais mais bon maintenant ça a changé la
petrov sur des cats à 16 go by dames où
ils font qu'elle prend des cinq comme
cramique et pour ses trois copains qui
se prend d ouais
on a la structure un peu comme c'est ça
la même structure que la green fields
t'as pas fait j'ai six touchés ça les
noirs je comprends pas il ya des gens
qui peuvent jouer c'est la petrov sur
des quatre là bas rhinoise contre 2,4
ben non en fait engrosser pragmatique
c'est que tu dis j'ai les noirs jouent
pour faire nul avec les bons gestes et
de trouver un petit truc ça tu peux pas
j'ai enfin mois des ouvertures comme ça
quand l'esprit mais je veux rade me j'ai
mangé quasiment 300 points de plus je
peux pas je pense que je pourrais pas me
permettre de jouer ce genre d'ouverture
mieux au ballon mais toujours un petit
ajout d'un certain humour quoi bah ça
vous fait je sois comptait pas mécontent
de formule oui mais en général là haut
niveau ils font des tournées entre eux
nulle sérieux ça normal
ouais son cantal et noir en fait battu
fait nul tu es c'est bien etc les blancs
en bon ci a dû lui annuler mais tu as
quand même essayer d'embêter un petit
peu soir ça soit faire un test de
mémoire à ton adversaire souvent très
compliqué soit tu as vraiment une petite
idée sympa sur une ligne tuer cette
plante est l'adversaire des choses comme
ça mais avec les noirs puent faire une
nulle en force où tu joues pas un coup
et où travailler à la maison non tu
donnes pas un cd film laisse les joueurs
d'échecs en fait oui non vous n'êtes pas
c'est un énorme boulot la maison mais
mais par contre sur l'échiquier ouais tu
joues pas en fait c'est le monde à
l'envers en fait parce que tu pourrais
tu attendras de faire produire son
effort devant l'échiquier en partie
officielle ou quoi alors qu'en fait
c'est un peu plus tôt comme un iceberg
quoi c'est la partie immergée la partie
et tout cas avancé
du coup une petit rock joué bon faut
défendre des cinq un jour sûrement
prendre on sait 4 ou comment défendre en
fait c'est vrai on a attaqué trois fois
pendant que tu as fait si simple ouais
est-ce que ce call of china à 4 est ce
que tu vas khalip qua non mais c'est de
la merde à 4 j'en sais rien faire un
tube sur quel et prends tu peux penser
dès qu'il prend des quatre oies des
trucs comme ça
abel fait tu vois qu'il prend qu'il
prendrait quatre l'idée c'est que si les
bleus reprennent des captures prendra
quatre actes à tour et si et si et si
quoi qu'est ce que je voulais jouer en
photo mais là je sais pas ouais mais du
coup on n'est pas mécontent dans le sens
où il ya moins de pression sur des 5
et puis si jamais tu fais des français
ou quoi et à 3 tu t'es bien donner les
cases noires avec les noirs étaient
contents des champions 1-3 tu te fais
plus chaste et on fout ta bim un peu les
cages marges seront des adversaires
parce que dans l'enveloppé en b2 donc il
ya tout un réseau de gaz qui va devenir
plus faibles et ça peut être cool mais
c'est ce qui fait passer à 3 4 non non
non pas sur louxor en l'air un jour mais
peut-être d'essai avant par contre ouais
donc je serai bien dépensé 4 et est à 3
s'il n'y a pas de contre-indication à
mais des problèmes parce que des
français s'il ya trop de fois france et
3 es tu peux garder tonton de plus tu
feras bessin et puisque tu as envie de
faire
donc je pense les blancs doivent
reprendre ce pion et sont là à 3 à 3
c'est bien tu te prends les cases noires
tel fameux tour à cinq qui peut arriver
un jour on en parlait la partie d'avant
qui serait pour partir d'un autre côté
c'est le thème de la journée ouais voilà
bah en fait j aurais pas pensé de base
mais comme j'en ai parlé et cinq mille
et une ati mais voilà donc donc on verra
donc qui avait lieu qui a troqué le kata
elle veut faire à 300 qu'il faut compter
3 c'est pas mal joué à trois elles
veulent faire l achat c est le flou va
partir bah sûrement des six pour le coup
mais parce que tu peux être faux à cinq
je serai aussi la sphère la barre il
aurait rien à y faire donc on décide
c'est normal france ccaf et bat
normalement les morts vont essayer de
faire au 5 j'imagine c'est un plan
normal qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre à s'en faire toujours dans ses
structures ses 65 65
et si on n'arrive à rien faire c'est que
c'est pas top donc sinon elle va essayer
d'être une tour on sait 8 et je pensais
5 mai ce sera une des deux options
qu'elle va tenter de faire merci à
allouer cas pour la leçon est parfait
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
importantes sont quand même parce que vu
que c'est un stream qui durent longtemps
il faut pas qu'ils soient trois heures
de souffrance pour les oreilles mais non
mais j'espère enfin je pense que je vais
investir dans un nouveau micro parce que
là j'en ai acheté un genre tout début de
gamme et probablement je vais augmenter
un peu tu vois les voleurs il est arrivé
un truc incroyable c'est que jorge ait
été contacté pour un mec qui est
l'intermédiaire d'une compagnie
compagnie aérienne en fait demandé voilà
tu fais un clip déchets il va apparaître
dans la bibliothèque des vidéos genre
pour les gens qui sont dans l'avion sont
dans l'avion
oui du coup et c'est
quand tu fasses mais du wat un talent
fou ok écoulé du coup du coup voilà je
si vous prenez rda dolomiti vous allez
me voir dans le métier pour les
dolomites
c'est un truc allemand si je ne me
trompe je disais bien que les allemands
n'ont aucun goût
nous voilà donc c'est cool bros
et du coup c'est quoi comme clipser l'on
souhaite que l'on gardé 20 à 45 minutes
et m'a dit et le but c'était juste
d'expliquer les échecs du coup j'ai fait
j'ai fait un match comme très concrète
yvon et voilà quoi dit enfilade comme
dans une bulle est testé catia v5 sa
part inquiété pour les blancs et
normalement la partie cette fois que
parce que là quand même une minute sans
corde contre 15 secondes ce serait
étonnant gardant situation mais on sait
on se les multiples sont possibles et
donc dames 1 en un coup sont possibles
alex a atteint ses limites
là ça veut dire que difficilement
défendables pour des pleins ouais mais
bon c'est pas dans le premier de ce qui
peut arriver tu vois alors elles veulent
enlever trois patrons bien allégée des
505 games tout quoi les cinq logique ya
plein de coups mais faut juste faire
gaffe tu vois qu'il prend le 5e jeu
entre espace h 4 h 5 kg 6 à toi je suis
bon faut y aller fort mais tout ça est
ce qu'avec tu te relais comme tu disais
que ça desservait des dolomites
mais oui je m'en lasser la région
d'italie
c'est un peu les montagnes tout ça après
vers venise au dessus ok la porte aux
organisations de huy fans c'est bien
pour elle et merci à scarface
cg nous allons c'est un rêve
sympa merci je connais non non non tu as
tout le monde donc je dis plus d
intelligent mais je sais pas si dit qu
il a arrêté son stream et non jeudi par
les échecs je sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
trop regarder chez désolé mais je dire
je change pas c'est un peu comme ça je
trouve il anime bien il est il est
plaisant
il salue hp qui ne connaît pas le pacino
enfin si bien sûr je connais mieux
regarder enfin nettement moins les films
de mafia et tout c'est pas du tout mon
truc mais il a fait d'autres trucs mais
après ça qui était très connu pour
scarface maïs le parrain de ça mais
j'aime le sport ça va d'espoir ah ouais
tu veux dire il a fait un coach de boxe
à un moment ou un autre comme ça il a
pas fini comme ça weight football
américain s'appelle any given sunday en
version originale ou l'enfer du dimanche
et il est beau acteurs de danse et
jimmie foxx cameron diaz
ll cool j qui joue dedans c'est un
symbole eh ouais
l'associé du diable ou du be bop au
sujet d'un film joue le diable en fait
chaud la mafia c'est un peu ses parents
donc quand même plus appeler tout 80
entre son désir même pas ma génération
de films genre je veux dire en ce moment
il n'y a pas de films qui sortent avec
eux et quel punch qua non rischmann qui
était sortie sur explique ne sais pas
pour toi parce que ces mafias exact je
n'ai pas regardé dit que marié l'on va
presser un peu de temps même s'il a tout
ça
donc si tu aimes pas tu aimes pas mais
[Musique]
et puis je sais pas quoi du coup c'est
quoi tes films moi mes films c'est plus
ce genre les thrillers et j'aime bien
tout ce qui est comédie comédie
romantique bon c'est un genre mien tu
vois mais en fait ce genre maintenant et
j'ai tellement pas le temps de regarder
les films quelques enjeux quand je
regarde j'ai juste envie de me détendre
tu vois ce genre de mettre mon cerveau
en pause et du truc faut pas juger parce
que parce que j'ai regardé quasiment
tous les films d'hitchcock et j'ai
regardé pas mal de trucs de réalisateurs
me en ce moment c'est surtout j'ai envie
de mettre mon cerveau imposé courtois et
ouais mais ouais d'en faire un film qui
est un thriller thème ya toujours des
kits avec al pacino x est plus poli way
a chuté juste policiers tout ça il a
fait pas mal
ouais bon c'est juste un grand amateur
d'histoire et donc de niro thème pas
trop non plus j'ai surtout vu dans
d'autres que les trucs de m'affirmer
ouais du coup j'aime bien et je trouve
ça très drôle mais la piqûre ça gueule
mais le fan est pas mal
bakou bibeau et c'est la vie moi je suis
plutôt je suis plutôt jiména je suis
plutôt rainbow slint je vois c'est plus
d'acteurs du beau gosse quoi ouais non
en vrai jean ali incroyable et genre
c'est un très très bon acteur vous
précis dit jamie il a tout il ya tous
les dix caprio alors pourquoi on s'en
fou contre les deux ouais il a pris un
coup deux yeux
ouais mais bon là à temps et il envoie
le korhogo pathé dans roméo juliette
remue plus juliette d'ailleurs savez
dans titanic il est là dans the big
chill et là ils courent sur la plage
il pas mal c'est ce trait aux échecs ou
cinéma écoute je pense que les deux fans
culture et oui mais beaucoup j'ai vu
ennemis évidemment j'ai vu une nuit et
wayne rooney capitaux j'aime bien vos
acteurs mais voilà bon ok ok bon voilà
porthus eux c'est moins intéressant de
tout ça un paquet on va attendre qu'il
ya un truc qui se passe
alors il peut faire un piège tué de
calais reste 4 tu attends que
l'adversaire pas sexiste pour je ne sais
quelle raison du fait qu'il g6 ta foi
qui a l'habitude d'écouter les jeux de
piste non mais en fait qu'est h 4 6 pas
que pour qui est si c'est pour faire 4 5
évidemment mais si alors jécistes fait
s'appelle terre ça défend les 15 mai
puis du coup tu fais que la f4 touvre la
position let's go allez on y va la fois
pop et web et les blancs font plutôt
mieux le fou c4 il est bien il est bien
il est pas derrière les pionniers devant
donc il tape sur f7 il fait mal quoi ça
fou qui montre les dents à prix web vont
prendre fcm à tanger c'est ton père la
tour le fou est attaqué voilà le sauve
c'est bien là vouloir doubler les
tourelles va très très vite shoei fans
par rapport à hakone roues oui
du coup aucune somme n'est c'est bien
d'accord je regarderai
euh je serai pas que je connais bien son
nom mais nous on est bien là franchement
franchement année bien même en tout cas
j'ai pas parlé pour fabien mais non mais
j'aime pas de film en fait tourner on va
très très bien
est ce parce que l'on devine ah bon
c'est pas là les jouets sont se
prélassent elle arrive après ça se joue
en même temps évidemment un cinéma donc
en fait on en a quand même bien 3 4 ap
plaisir aujourd'hui
il est donc bon qu'on est bien que là
c'est juste une petite mise en bouche
mais c'est la plus belle affiche à jour
normalement mais après on verra contre
kosteniuk et la gmp bizarre qu'ils aient
mis d'abord ce match là mais c'est
peut-être des questions d'horaires des
maîtres quand même le masque alors le
plus intéressant sur pied après on a eu
très chaud
ouais ouais je sais pas trop leur
horaire c'est vrai que sur ça mais ouais
c'est vrai que je peux dire chaque
format qu'un assez spécial non mais
outre le fait que c'est très longtemps
tout ça mais même en fait tu es toujours
le même premier tour c'est chaud quand
même tu trois fois au premier tour ça
raconte crèche bon et là tu vois une
fois tu vois deux fois c'est la revanche
mais il ya un moment on n'est pas bien
de faire douze mille fois le même match
qu'en fin ici détrompe toi même
peut-être treize mille fois quoique bien
sûr qui est le meilleur
non ça ça même plus de sens
les joueuses aussi bas c'est sûr non
plus en plus samantha moins de moins
d'enjeu mais là pour iphone je pense est
assez important si elle gagne le tour
elle peut peut-être se qualifier pour la
grande finale
j'ai pas trop tu as comme celle de
grandpuits et aspi alors je vais essayer
faut mettre le classement ça c'est cool
comme ça on veut faire des petits contes
tout ça mais au classement
alors hein faut faire faire des maths ne
sais pas je suis pas très forte mais
rassure de calcul mental et chiffres et
des lettres et où enfin surtout les
chiffres pour le coup non je n'ai vu que
j'ai vu qu'à ce moment et j'ai regardé
c'était intéressant en fait alors je
vais te classement des secondes parce
que je crois qu'il ya au chenil à et
chine à la fin j'ai pu conduire et goût
nina qui ont même honte de points non
alors donc là
le classement là non on le voyait le
voit le voir à main il va pas les points
justement développer les points save est
embêtant si vos pas les patrons on le
fait à l'oral quoi doucher nina elle a
20 points mais attends n'allait pas
mieux à jour en corse ne s'est pas mis à
jour mais en fait ça ça veut dire tu
joues pas voilà tu joue pas donc à un
petit au moins aller un petit zoom g
faire un petit noir comment on fait pour
faire un zoom au fond ouais sinon tu
faire une capture écran tu crées trop
compliqué bon un gros zoom alors là ça
va parce que là vous voyez donc avant la
dame le dernier grand prix à table chez
nina en tête avec 22 points mais qui
peut pas jouer donc la cire un peu
doublé il ya l'agglo qui balle au point
mort ne veut pas non plus donc 2001 qui
a déjà passé un tour bah il est passé
devant l'agglo mieux à dieu fait
elle a perdu et a perdu contre
contre a perdu en quarts on est perdu on
est contre claude eyraud mais du coup je
crois que ces deux points thème l'écart
parce qu'avec un pc le premier tournant
de jouer comme ce petit voilà la date et
le conte l'histoire son tour l'est le
tarn
ouais une jeune femme donc il me semble
wake est normalement goulinat elle est
qualifiée
je pense du 22ème et vont regarder les
fans avec 10 gagne le fait 12 22 ouais
et kosteniuk chez le médecin point g pas
qu'on marque 10 points mais on évoque
les marques 10.22 aussi bon qu'on sait
pas en fait c'est la décision complète
le suspens et elles sont à son cou à son
comble il ya des points de suture et
nous dit 12 le vainqueur 8 le finaliste
ok donc en fait faut que will fans que
ces news gagne le tournoi tu les as même
sarah scellier ne tourne à la veine de
way difficilement mais peut être est
stable sa demi demi pour moi qui
s'annonce est en forme mais pas très
loin ouais ouais c'est mince intéressant
du coup ce que tout le monde jusqu'à la
6e place tout le monde peut
potentiellement être qualifiés c'est un
truc de fou quoi oui ok alors du coup
cette partie j'ai besoin de bouger il ya
une tortue cela je vois les chicken bon
ça va oui où va gagner rarement elle est
encore plus normalement ça devrait
suffire
et là elle a dix secondes d'avancé en
plus donc voulu faire une fourchette
peut être un moment pour gagner le tour
mais les voilà donc à prendre le lead je
sais pas s'il va entendre pour une
quatrième partie ou pas
moyen-tour de plusieurs ouais mais c'est
désormais un point en fait nous sommes à
100%
du coup ça y est c'est bien tard tomber
sur tes pattes ouais pim dégagé touquet
donc ça c'est un truc vous pouvez faire
dans vos parties qu'on a un large
avantage matériel vous rendre une partie
pour simplifier et qui adversaire a
quasiment plus rien et vous gagnez en
sifflotant
c'est un truc qui peut faire des fois
aussi en fait des fois et j'ai tendance
à vouloir simplifier alors c'est pas du
tout genre d'effort vraiment calculé
pour finir tu vois mais j'ai tendance à
des fois trop simplifié mois alors ouais
complexifie à fond quoi c'est à dire
plus je vais mettre 3 4 400 l'air j'ai
plus de chance on a des fois j'ai enfin
c'est généralement des positions temps
max mais où je suis mieux ok c'est me
dépose ouais donc je disais alors des
fois je joue comme des mecs la pression
et induit clairement genre plus de +3 et
j'ai l'impression que je veut simplifier
20 pour parce que j'ai la flemme de
quelqu'un mais en fait vous [ __ ] des
fois faut juste juste quelqu'un d'assez
mais je calcule pas pas trop en général
disons que j'ai tendance à me plier
trois minutes à mon intuition question
et ouais c'est ça ben après un temps ce
qui est bien c'est identifier là le
souci c'est de te faire violence ouais
mais je fais je suis à ma que cette
tactique en ce moment essayé de faire un
truc à la faible en plus donc bon je
vais une partie ok je veux bien la règle
a n'a pas du tout je viens de commencer
finul
moi j'ai la française ça bizarre ça je
sais pas ah oui n'avait dakar me fais
importe quoi en fait
mais je vous des coupons vite et bien
pas bien je suis pas sûr et j'ai
peut-être raté là en fait partie
pour que je te laisse est mort là c'est
mort parce que j'attaque tous contre
tous
gfr sur le petit coup là comme damien
les gens pilotes c'est magnifique
attends je vais ramener la dame par là
s'est jamais un jour je peux faire tout
reprend f3 pas amener des fois que des
fois je vois pas comment l'adversaire et
je joue en fait ouais c'est tellement un
couanau d'un coup
la seule marche pas c'est ton idée ok
bah ça m'a l'air bien ça bon ben ça va
il veut en revanche à les arrange ça il
ne restait une reste un peu de bruit
c'est pas des grands échecs mais bon
c'est rigolo pas c'est sympa c'est
divertissant
allez on n'attaque l'heure parce que on
a quand même envie de lui ouvrir la
position de dire autre chose
oui mais bon non j'ai justement vulgaire
nous l'avons je me suis stream officiel
de thiès comme tout ça tout ça j'ai
peut-être pas dévoiler ma vraie
personnalité comme à ce petit jeu tout
le mystère ok mais là j'ai gagné encore
facile quoi je gagne facile notre autre
option sympa le droit et c'est là il va
tomber quoi madame bisson sueur petit
présent passant je sais pas si tu
connais la règle des la prison parce
qu'à l'époque où il aura appris un truc
c'est bien qu aux prises avec son groupe
prise en passant il va gérer son nom loc
alexandre emboîtement pas x
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que les gens
avaient dit qu'on était en deuil thunder
a et va parler
il m'a demandé si j'étais romaine policy
il connaît son profil me tate à la
meinau mec pendant un match d une minute
ils te disent que d'aller voir mon
profil quoi c'est bien que faire le
deuil thunder en fait verrons comment tu
veux tu gères ça sediba
et à l'heure moldave pas non mais le nom
c'est en direct comment tu peux savoir
que je suis robin quoi apparemment
cliquer sur ton profil
ben oui pourquoi pas d'accord mais genre
le mec en une minute tu as eu le temps
d'aller voir mon profil quoi il est
vachement plus intéressés par son profil
que par la partie en soi assez rare
bientôt cancer ou la pipe à eau ou là
pourquoi j'aime bien à huit mois
n'importe quoi comme ça pour rebondir
j'ai craqué j'ai bien craquer il a vu
j'étais une wm ça y est inna molière
c'est alexandre où tu te trouves l'ont
fait avec ces questions oh là là encore
passants qui nous fait on l'a classé
mais pourquoi les gens me donnent des
pièces c'est du bullet mais quand même
je veux dire je sais je suis pas très
forte mais quand même c'est pas la peine
de me donner des pièces que je dirige et
pas besoin des deux pour gagner quoi que
je crois que son petit frère joris
envahissons max max 8 sur quoi rager
[ __ ] j'ai encore une pièce cas ça va
ça va il perd pas une pièce quant à
l'échec si tu voulais je veux pas te
déconcentrer joujou way est un jet voilà
tu vois tu as rendu ça va se gâter
penser à ces horribles
quelle horreur ala sayej et comment ça
marche
j'ai commencé à mal jouer parce que là
je reçois ça va très très mal se passer
la doublette sur le passé ok ok ok
pourtant j'étais bien parti mais est
passé et ses pulls est un navet et je
sais pas il reste que même temps de
pause et je chante c'est sympa de faire
déposer en jouant j'en vois tu peux
parler une fois si tu veux faire
d'ailleurs ouais mais prévoit pas marché
après mon garagiste policiers j'espère
qu'un truc ont un coût 35 10 35 ans il
faut que j'aie faut que je gagne cette
partie à toute heure à trader faire il
sera intéressé ouais t'es pas et tu es
pas terrassé et là ça y est tu vois et
j'ai attendu de compression non mais j'y
jouais bien
bakou apa
mais je vais abandonner j'ai abandonné
ce fait chier parce que parce que j'ai
pas envie mais bon allez ajout l'arrêt
et appartient comme ailleurs les
joueuses à marie josée lord la prochaine
pause et je vais et je vais continuer
après bon allez vous abandonnent parce
que il est trop fort c'est dommage parce
que qu'est-ce que j'étais pas faire là
alors qu'honeywell que les blancs qui je
voue une sorte de réty on va dire donc
donc on verra donne alors el mardja de
l'arago zinvié aussi trop théorique
c'est beaucoup trop intelligent je dois
je dois changer
et ouais donc ce recchi qui est
relativement intéressante d'énergie c5
ça c'est un plan c c'est un plan très
connu de fer structure de benoni la
cesci ouais tu peux faire tu pousses
juge faire du beach rugby f1 il ya plein
de trucs c'est souple mais c'est peyo
pour les blancs tout cas mais je crois
qu'on plus rauque et que sa date normale
mois la bouffe et je pense que c'est bon
qu'on en parle je prends a bien dû
cavale mais en fait du pion c'est
jouable aussi et peut-être six bogueys
et 6 7 6
ouais donc b6 voilà c'est assez normal
et non elle veut le faire quoi foot 17
qui sait s'ils sortaient des pièces sur
les cases normal peut-être mettre le cap
sur l'avant poste en d4 1 jour mais les
blancs est clairement si un jour tu fais
des quatre temps une structure assez
symmetrical à ce qu'elle fait mais tu
espères était fou sur les grandes
diagonales obtenir un petit truc avec le
fou j'ai deux parents qui est plus fort
que le fourbe et ça te fout c'est donc
voilà on vous le rappelle 30 minutes
cinq lycéens 30 minutes et 3 puis 5 et
10 minutes de à +1 du coup c'est non
c'est bon je peux tu sais quel chrono
mais c'est quand j'ai eu ces quatre
parties et donc ouais ou qui mène 2 1
après la première session well as l'air
au dessus dans le match mais bon on sait
jamais ce que tu joues encore le
contrebandier albin étant donné que je
n'ai jamais joué
il serait non pourquoi te j'ai joué je
trouve pas ça mais n'importe quoi space
et je n'ai jamais joué aussi la l'ofec
montreuil leur fric spike rang des
captures écran welch et ont invoqué à
tout sauf à une partie l'état mais
probablement que j'ai les blancs en fait
oui pour je vois pas quel parti super
mais j'avais les blancs en fait donc je
ne joue pas c'est pas moi qui les ai
joués en fait pas si tu as laurent
hénart ouais c'est sûr c'est pas moi je
sais qui c'était et je sais que c'est
pas moi qu'ils aient joué donc sur
certains
et qu'onéreux qui est très très lointain
d'abaisser ces mamans quoi je sais pas
pourquoi le silence
probablement qu'ils attirent fin et tu
prends un qui prend du calalou ouais bon
ça me régale alors envie de trouver un
truc mumbai à rennes a trouvé en toi te
dis que tu as joué rêve démentir voilà
c'est pas bien de mentir je donne quoi
tu m'as en fait c'est quoi le projet et
oui oui c'est un moment mais du coup
alors jusqu'à d'accélérer un peu parce
que ça peut être un problème le temps
d'une paix sur également cercle a pour
l'instant il est spécial donc cet
échange des changes qui change tout koné
même fait un peu coincé genre tu vois
qu'on est con et maman et voulait créer
un as aimé soit il écrit un message
comme ça avec un comme ça jean tu vois
elle fait penser à ça en fait c'est pour
ça le vote des 9
oui non mais du coup et même louis fans
avant 1-0 sousse il bien jouer fou 4 et
gagner intense et les traquent les
blancs plus de 80 jours ce contrôle des
cases c'est pas mal peut-être même d'amd
et tu repars vers baisse a touché l'os
tournage bien aligner les pièces le
fatal bazooka dali keane non en fait ça
donne derrière les tours ils appellent
ça le pistolet des liquides bondar les
fouilles à ça pas de nom donc bon je
fais le bazooka des liquides est ok non
mais ça se passe juste normal on verra
ainsi si dans une peau de banane qui va
partir mais oui si on veut faire pour
penser à tour ses 8 puis sinon c'est le
voeu que la colonne
ben quoi voilà jeté sur spikes tu vois
c'était sûr j'avais les blancs merci
papa tu vas jouer quand même à démentir
peut-être qu'à pas jouer des quatre si
tu voulais pas de jouer au hockey
du coup je vais avoir un peu de rapports
matériel à les noirs je vais être le cas
vals les bains avec le fou mais je crois
pas que le cahier sur un bon bout il a
une bonne case centrale il est bien
implanté battant sur menace de maths
il faut la voir elle l'a vu naître
bref ça tu vas damage 5 on repart je ne
sais pas trop ce schéma auquel fâche
cinq bons mètres joue à fond mais après
on connait rôle une bonne pointe de
vitesse
beaucoup de temps est-ce que des buffets
lettre par lettre qu'après le maire en
écriture intuitive plus c'est parti mais
j'ose indienne cas une belle pointe de
vitesse si on voit g4 forcément bon pour
s'est montré fort ne peut en être
autrement a capté le coup quoi jaquette
[Musique]
coup de cheval le faire dans le cadre
peut-être on savait qu'on prend le
défendrai k5 mesdames eu quatre bouquets
même se rapprocher du roi de perse
même si on n ya pas trop de danger c'est
doit toujours faire un nul mais bon on
écoute 4 secondes contre 20 ça se
passait tout et n'importe quoi il va
repartir et que saddam sûrement pas tant
ils sont bien placés ici le rôle assez
en sécurité pour défendre aussi c'est
avec les noirs jar jar bref c'est tour
c'est tout je sais pas avait cinq mois
je comprends ta j'aurais pas fait 5 ou
te le dire ma maison constaté bill roi
alors serait peut être trop avoir déjà
le père du site mais qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait pourquoi
c'est qu'avec les noirs je comprends pas
super super sur soyez un truc que j'ai
pas vu soit mais là ça va voir d'autres
c'est l'horaire tutelle nathalie roy
faible en fait oui et tout est fondé g5
h600 plus et laissent de la joueuse
chinoise
ouais tu te prends juste un gâchis su
comment tu fais là tu te fais bouffer
les pions tuer les changes et les dames
s'il faut ben ok elle va les prendre des
quatre actions allez c'est fini c'est
fini
dominés terrible qu'elle peut juste
faire des petits rois de 7,3 g 8 c dans
son petit coin là bas mais peut-être
trouvé jeu pour le gain je ne sais pas
pourquoi elle mène 2 à 1 dans le match
s'est produit
et du coup alors lance grave le match 2
et ouais mais wilson qui passerait n'en
fait elle joue mieux
dans le fond c'est que l'arrêt n'a
jamais été dans trois ans danger dans le
jeu dont une partie mc2 donc à un moment
tu as tu eu le trac qui permettait la
maman nallet
est ce que j'ai vu des échecs oui tout à
fait je faisais des études mais ça m'a
saoulé met au fond tout d'une sortie des
clips pour les avions qui s'est lancé
quoi influence euse co pilote d'avion je
sais pas où est ce que tout ça va
s'arrêter
ok il faut aussi de quelle défense on
s'en trouveront les blancs je crois que
je suis pro question envie de faire
bouger 5 aussi bon elle a bouffé avec
l'intention de faire de faire bouger 5
sur cd ou aussi d'effets avec les blancs
sur série que j'ai des d4 juste pour
reprendre le centre fixe et la structure
et c'est parce que moi je vis des échecs
oui mais même pas que du jeu oui j'avais
dire surtout pas que 10 juin ce moment
non seulement de façon c'est pas
possible
ok peut-être pour moi c'est pierre je
sais pas mais parce que c'est dur qu'en
fait je joue pas mal ce sont les 20
meilleurs français mais c'est pas assez
pour prétendre en vivre que par les
tournois au quartz à une concurrence qui
est mondial tu as vu des joueurs qui
sont plus forts et voilà non par contre
je donne des cours je fais pas mal
d'activités des vidéos geste sortie des
dvd des vidéos séries j'ai écrit des
articles des livres mois des cours et
des stages je fais je fais pas mal de
choses quoi je bosse ouais je bosse a
toujours un lien avec les échecs en
général mais c'est pas forcément le jeu
en tant que soi après je produis être un
joueur actif un certain la retraite non
plus je joue par équipe
je fais des tournois acheter des choses
mais c'est pas juste faire les tournois
kim pernelle ma vie pas d'ailleurs ça ne
permet pas la ligne sajoo mois d'août
est complet non j'ai pas mais qui
complète les deux sont il ya encore de
la place
alors ils sont ils sont soumis hoyé quoi
5 6 personnes quoi mais c'est mon métier
oui c'est mon métier mais c'est un
métier un peu touche-à-tout quoi tu dois
je suis toi tu as toujours toujours
chercher quoi faire bah tu es passé
varietà pas de cdi t'appelle l'argent
comme à la fin du mois dont tu vas
bouger le chien quoi ça c'est clair
c'est un truc j'ai appris aussi
récemment qu'en version cabaret c'est
toujours je serais vraiment question
enfin c'est comme ça c'est un côté ouest
la mise en prêt juste des passes sur le
web moi j'ai déjà commencé avant donc
voilà en fait moi ça va pas changer
grand chose de ce point de vue là même
si ben j'espère qu'on n'aura pas nous
confinement d'un même la meute voit cet
été j'étais censé je détourne naissance
est sympa je vais le stage unis au
canada ou quoi j'étais journaliste en
avant je joue en italie afin de faire
plein de trucs plutôt cool bas c'est
tombé à l'eau attention on peut pas
s'apitoyer sur son sort fait aux frais
pas de chance faut juste se bouger en
fait
bah oui parce que son chalet ça fera pas
avancer les choses
barbin ok peut-être adjointe de trois
jours entre m
la merde c'est con c'est dommage en
effet sa basse dommage love faut bien on
sait quand même sinon voila sinon si je
compte refaire ou le chinois huawei
fasse mon général tu vois c'est pas trop
un choix quoi donner l'opportunité ou
pas et là j'avais de la chance de
l'avoir et produire j'ai pas
spécialement poussé pour en faire un
autre allemand faut prendre un agent
faut quand même se bouger aller faire
des castings de faire des trucs à ce qui
est très particulier c'est un film
autour des échecs et de base je t'ai pas
de sens et je dors je faisais juste
consultants mais bon an mal an jeu plus
con c'est fait on m'a proposé en direct
sur le casting pourquoi pas pour voir
s'est bien passé j'ai bien réagi face à
la caméra
mais ça c'est fait mais c'était pas dans
une démarche de dire oui je veux être
acteur c'est comme ça mais c'était une
belle expérience découle céder pour
autant à l'étranger
voilà enfin si ça dépend ça dépend webb
a tendance à les pendre la force du
temps à moi par exemple je peux pas me
faire inviter à l'étranger parce que je
suis trop faible comme ben en fait le
truc genre moi j'ai pas trop me sortent
non plus j'imagine
par contre oui donc des fois les
tournois ils peuvent inviter ses deux
trucs différents alors soit ils payent
tous les pays que l'hôtel sur ip que
l'avion s'est dit tiens prends un peu
d'argent et vient enfin peu importe ça
ça dépend le tournoi et voilà donc ça tu
peux avoir des invités
genre tu fais un tournoi mondial
motorola pension complète ou je sais pas
quand il y en a d'autres où y'a rien et
ça ça dépend donc s'en fait souvent ça
tout moins cher que le tennis mais les
prix / - grossi mais du coup moi je
serais plutôt pour la famille invite en
fait beaucoup et que les prix soient
plus gros comme je donne mon avis ça
serait plus
plus facile pour tout le monde en fait
ce que l'ordinateur ils ne seraient que
les prix sur les tournois et vient qui
veut et les joueurs en fait tu vois les
joueurs locaux auraient plus de chance
de gagner des prix n'est pas ce que tu
aurais pas une concurrence de mai qu'on
sait pas ce qu'ils font là en fait on
les invite en sais pas pourquoi ils
parlent pas un mot ils ont taillé dans
leur chambre ils ont zéro plus sur le
temps dans cette fin il soit le club pas
là enfin même je préférais que ça pas là
en fait je leur ai alors que pourquoi on
les invite pour grimper leur billet
d'avion pour un peu leur hôtel bon donc
finalement si elle pas d'un vite ça me
choquerait pas après tu rends l'argent
en prix ah oui ça donc je sais pas c'est
juste un modèle dans le jeu qui est fait
comme ça
bon ben maintenant mieux non bis je sais
pas dans quel sens où le voir c'est
comme ça pareil mais ça me dérangerait
pas qu'ils aient plus de plus trop
d'avis toi vous avez combien des cui je
vais pas aux deux pour ma part je pense
mais pas plus
mais là et alors ça devient extrêmement
chaud je vais prendre ce podium parce
qu'il ya le fameux cloud âge c'est
terrible avait très mal autant retrouver
faut juste qu'elle joue descoings peu
étonnant à coeur aïe aïe aïe pas très
étonnant c'est parti qu'il a eu et au
puy du prend le lead qui prend le lead
bas-fonds te chercher des maracas barak
a toujours besoin de chailley secoue les
marqueurs aller à fond la tuque pour la
montage vous avez quelqu'un vous
paraissez ophtalmique mois deux mois
trois jeux pas un truc dans le sens dans
la com du rôle de l'ange monte en
puissance avec rue du grand choix qui
fait son match
ce que vous considérez que navette en
bretagne à moi je me suis nantaise un
peu d'adoptions lorsque bruce tous les
tous les nantais ils détestent mais
genre vraiment ils détestent un point
quand on dit ce qu ils sont bretons il
se revendique 90 et quand ils sont pas
breton ils sont juste nantais quoi ouais
oui enfin tu peux tu peux être les deux
en fait pas n'importe quoi tu lui aussi
être breton
bon brestois on va dire je passe il ne
pas les choquer les brestois s'est pas
en bretagne dans simple mais tu vaux
chez de français au passage et enfin que
tout être l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
et voilà on a plein de réactions
mais si je te répond steve qu'est ce que
le mont saint michel est à la vraie
ténois la normandie g20 la question se
pose même pas moi je ne connais pas
cette personne et je objectifs et ouidah
moines en moins dit bah oui on dit
tellement de monde il représente à
normandie au bassin mais nous mais nous
les normands en fait on devient très
très sensible genre à chaque fois qu'un
breton outils web le mont saint michel
et que vous appartient pas à noyen genre
pardon mais en fait mais en fait tu es
qui en fait mais pourquoi tu parles
genre du coup c'est à toi en fait le
mentionne il m'appartient
il me demanda de faire une vidéo de
promotion pour pour la compagnie
dolomites steyn qui va desservir le mont
saint-michel de seulement et il n'y a
pas des robots pour descendre en
parachute mais possible et puis on l'a
perdu en fait on est perdu la main alors
depuis l'a8 les maracas sauver là
[Musique]
c'était un rêve bas à leur tour
mais bon la connexion est de retour pour
jouer jouez un coût non mais elle est
plus là il a quitté deux amis des orgues
al-arich fuite
mais ce qu'on peut voir sans rajout et
ouais mais sauf qu'elle joue pas en vue
on veut bien fais pas tu peux tu peux la
suivre sur un statut qui ont déjà dit
ouais c'est dvd live alors la collection
écoulement sur moi c'est fini
un faisait trois jeux elle a perdu
combien de temps là sur ce coup a une
minute ou pic est atteint et lumière bah
ouais mais c'est normal
le courant passe mieux et salue bongrain
baisse ou bâcle c'est en jouant en ligne
les deux ailes c'est pas trop con sa
clause et chaque récemment la gamme fini
ses études elle vient d'être nommée plus
jeune prof de fac c'est wang zhen donc
donc elle a fait des trucs tu vois
fallait 2680 aux échecs pour une
université à côté c'est pas tout le
monde qui réagit qui réalise tout ça
donc peut-être que la mois le temps de
cinq ans sur les échecs et ça peut se
comprendre
puis après je vais en ligne toute façon
ça reste spécial tapas même
concentration tu as des soucis de
collection puis c'est toujours pareil
c'est pas pareil
une étude qui est sorti il ya quand même
ils ont envoyé donc comparer le niveau
de jeu des joueurs qui ont joué le
magnus invitationnal par rapport à leur
tour n'a en général en pl mais à la même
cadence rapide et avec les mêmes sans
enjeu financier parce que c'est facile
de dire oui monte vite soit un tartuffe
ou mal c'est pas votre budget il n'y a
pas d'argent à gagner bons là tu as deux
cent mille euros à gagner nom
normalement t'es un peu motivés quoi
mettre un peu de beurre même de crème
dans les épinards et est en fait il ya
17 % de plus de gars et 7% ces pannes
exotiques et donc un problème passons
sur internet avec la concentration je
pense avec le climat avec
plein de choses le moins d'implication
et avance un truc j'ai toujours ressenti
je trouve sur internet on joue moins
bien qu'en vrai problème de vision aussi
problème de d'application de ce que tu
veux mais c'est pas pareil et là j'ai
inclus pas les pointes de triche qui
évidemment c'est un autre souci là je
dis pas qu'à haut niveau ça triche vous
dans ce tournoi là je suis sûr que non
mais tu as tous état de problèmes fait
pour viser tourner en ligne ce qui fait
que moi je serais plutôt contre en fait
pas trop bien et en plus à d'autres
problèmes donc pourquoi faire tant pis
pour eux autres trucs quoi former un
jour le qu'ovide s'arrêtera et puis on
reprendra là où s'arrêtera jamais pareil
coup de faire un trajet mais vous
retrouvera en trouvera de solution mais
tout cas pour l'instant je souhaitais
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup tu auras de
faire et qu'elle jamais eu du grand
niveau
mais c'est clair un muscle et que sais
je sais bah oui mais bon il ya pas 20%
de mystique non plus c'est quand même un
écart significatif surpris missclick
peut-être ça joue pour 3% le truc at on
expliqué le jazz et partage et merci
pour les compliments les gars vous êtes
très gentils ils sont rôle mais ils sont
aussi très gentil non ils sont cools
eh ben on sait encore se finir
chaussettes parties à prendre et satya
b4 qui va voler la serbie h 4 h 5 trucs
comme ça et c'est tendu les marques ont
vu l'homme qui ont passé de l'autre côté
mais les blancs qui tente qui tentent
leur va-tout de adel al elle elle joue
par pat déjà bien des américains
j'ai dit bien joué un peu vite mal joué
en fait est maligne ou sinon c'est la
même format alors oui et non les gros
tournois en lan real c'est des parties
lentes sont partis vers 4-5 heures
donc là ils n'ont pas fait les stable
par rapport à ça ils ont fait ce stade
par rapport à des tournois rapide je
perds tu vois quand il est content chez
ce tour qui ont été les championnats du
monde de l'it et rapide quand des trucs
comme ça donc ils ont pris des cadences
similaire qui qui donne justement un
point de comparaison
tu vas pas prendre une partie dure six
heures pour une partie ambulatoire
internet sas et clark lors les tutoriaux
aucune valeur peut-être que je sais pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas me servir ses
tuiles et 32 peut-être que faire durer
le truc je sais pas a abandonné voilà ça
ne mange pas mais je sais pas peut-être
que la connexion est un souci que
mandela time out je ne sais pas je
trouvais ça existe mais non c'est bon
sernhac se rejoue et quatre en corse un
bon elles sont pas très original mais à
quoi a offert trois félins voilà bon je
pense que jacques et ses 3000 fans soit
une habituée du truc
voilà voilà ce qu elle bouffe voilà des
profs ou 7 en général et vont sortir le
fougeux dam des deux grands roch lener
deux options sogec petit rock recomposée
sais pas trop dangereux soient toujours
grand cas lors qu'on les blancs vont le
faire aussi c'est ce qu'elle fait en
train de faire et refaire d'amd sata et
donc le jeu et grand roque ce qui est ce
qui est plus solide et ce alors des fois
les bleus auraient plutôt pour thème 10
kg 5e donné la paire de shoes pas si
grave
je crois que les blancs faut essayer de
prendre de l'espace si tu peux
j'installe fait rage 3g 4 4 c'est bien
mais on peut y arriver
or à bien jouer est ce que le grand rush
je sais pas grand en fait faut juste
regarder ce qui se passe sur caïds et 4
passes que cai prend dame prend sécher
entre garde à 7 on te regarde entre
garder g7 vous faut et c'est justement
petit par ce truc parce que le plus
raide c'est un piège way we et n'ont pas
froid de toi parce qu'il y avait trois
souvenirs avez deux je suis enfermée
avec des plans de liszt tapuai de suez
avec à 4 à 5 20 à 5 à 4
[Musique]
les pièges fischer le purin des voix la
faillite en âge de monsieur nous un peu
la même chose d'ailleurs on a eu le fin
mot en fait de prier le bouffer ce pion
dans sa vie jamais été un petit quoi la
chaussée après la partie du match tu
vois c'est pas non plus c'est juste que
parce qu'il a obligé 3 c'est pas
possible il beaucoup trop fort donc soit
il c'est un défi à dire oui mais avec
une pièce de moi je vais pas peur après
je sais que c'était pas si mal quand ils
ont repassé la barre c'est que les ordis
en fait ça fait nul c'est juste
absolument de faire ça ouais en fait il
est des moins de fermer plus tard
j'étais juste absurde de soude dans la
merde à capturer complètement égal avant
c'est je ne sais pas pourquoi il a fait
ça c'est quand même dangereux
j'ai mon général tu vas pas trop hein
hein tout là-bas enfermé
c'est pour énerver marine chat pas de
quoi un oui avant il avance tout était
mixte mais depuis deux trois ans et puis
marine piaf alors les chevaux étaient
sur l'échangé prises des 4 dame prend
bon lit double attaque un peu quand même
sur a7 et gestion quand même défendre et
7 en priorité et quand on perd g7 ont
purgé sept mois je m'en vais la sécher
en fait parce que toujours dg vite tu
renvoies d'amendé 4 1 et puisque paraît
de partir et tué la tour âge tu prends à
acheter donc qu'est-ce qu'elle avions
pourquoi le fier g7 comme ça pourquoi le
prend pas et l a pas vu un simplement la
tête c'est juste une faute
ouais ouais j'suis pas soutenu voilà
prix j'espère de tout coeur fou prend à
de boom
voilà donc roy prendra me 6,3 bouge dame
prend eu deux bons soit lisse et
peut-être quand même pas si mal pour les
blancs mais d'abord il ya quand même une
idée c'est bien fait et c'était bien
joué bravo à ce que va d'abord tenter
projet de fonds de ce foutu de faire un
petit roi siens mais c'est un peu chelou
chaud je prendrai mon temps
ouais d'amasha robert dames 3 2 c'est
sûr et je dirais des médecis peut-être
mal mais je sais ça reste sympa pour les
blanchons ouais parce que tu te crées un
pur beurre salé le roi ça va avancer
vous pouvez changer son jeu venir
échanger tient très vite pourquoi de la
colonne quoi vous promets et puis bon ok
on pour veiller les purins autour des 3
comme ça j'ai pas mes g4 ou quoi ce
trois notes correctes
elle propose deux pistes de dames pour
les deux tours c'est pour ça que lui
propose en fait je pense pas qu'elle
doive prendre acte et noir parce que
dans trente ans reprend tout renvoie à
deux problèmes c'est que tu arrives
cette attaque est situé 5 tours 7 sur
adam and see donc
elle a fait d'alger 6 g iii hockey
petite pression quand même pris un tour
aussi supportable affaire à six blessés
et les bas du couloir
ouais bah je pensais de faire pareil et
non tous racistes aurait vite semblé
normal oui fans qu'il a juste joué un
peu vite position elle a pas grand chose
de mieux mais quand même ton pions
passer à l'est le droit potentiels c'est
un truc et c'est pas mal et là on voit
un intérêt de ses pions doublé ce qu'ils
vont bien bloqué la majorité adverse
elle a beau avoir du coup aux trois
pions compte quatre c'est pas si simple
prennent aux créatures blessés
pourquoi pourtant c'était écrit un fab
libye du coup ben c'est pas les aléas
pâte afin que tu as pris pour kevin quoi
ouais ouais c'est l'habitude et qui veut
il va me payer pendant mon niveau de fer
à 30 leurs neurones
je donne des cours je garantirai je sais
pas où tu commences c'est pas ton niveau
actuel ses chevrettes et je ferai de mon
mieux mais ça dépendra aussi un tueur
pour un scandale une fois comme un
soutien des quatre échecs
ouais ça hein quoi pas s'il veut être
sûr d'être en g53 lancar est quand même
[Musique]
et de sa canne et qui en fait je crois
que c'est une connerie d'où il vient
j'ai quatre cesser ces bêtes quoi c'est
pas top top bakou de l'année quoi quels
horaires et se fait et se fait un peu et
intubé techniquement ouais mais j'aurais
10 h 58 sont patentes et damages 3 jean
je pense que j'aurai les moyens jusqu'à
30 jours
mais ouais voilà du coup les moyens
enfin j'ai quatre là d'un match si ce
qui va arriver faut débloquer ce qu'ils
ont créé un jour aidé à mettre quatre
peut-être mesdames 3 59 4 et qu'on
ressent bien c'est tout d'abord avait
son revers aussi c'est peut-être en ifsi
ce g5 d'ailleurs si on peut la halle
meuse de trop un jour on pas trop vite
il n'y a pas de rupture
ah ben ouais c'est pas bête comme saddam
3,3 d'un médecin que c'est une idée
madame trop twilight
ah oui d'accord mais c'est ça le 4-1-4-1
train de se faire bouffer c'est
complètement foutu pour les blancs c'est
clair elle va faire dame cinq échecs et
g3 par exemple et après tu voir sécurisé
et hongrois tout cas s'il a quand même
attention à cela ouais d'autres optent
qu'ils aient chaque est d'amasser
d'affilée hockey
ce qui est accroché par 2,5 échec et je
viens je suis ok puis chaque bain super
super bravo bravo
elle est là elle est là elle est belle
même cap 3 et sur la d re partie de la
portion danse est finie la vente de
leurs mirettes sais que je mène d'un
point avant le but lors de ses six
minutes break d'affilée qui me veut moi
comme prof comment doit-il faire bas
alors il ya les stages ces stages bercy
veut en privé on a par ailleurs c'est
pas eu lieu mais tu peux m'écrire un
message tu m'écris sur ses soins comme
tu écris par email par facebook par
twitter instagram pas tu peux me trouver
quelque part tu m'envoies un message tu
me tues me dit tu me dit au profil ton
machin tes attentes et puis on voit si
si ça peut le faire ou pas on peut
tester mais bon comme ça ce stream pour
faire pour faire du téléachat c'était
comment des dicos en avance pourquoi pas
mais tu vois tu écris et puis on voit ça
bah oui ça va vrai que si tu vas voir
une petite pause j'allais me faire un
témoin du vingtième mois sur 10 mois je
parlais tout chat tu parles avec le chat
moi je vais me faire un thé je reviens
là tout de suite monté à quoi on ne sait
pas on aura tout à l'heure je prends
encore des boîtes de prendre des élèves
pendant un bon moment comme ça c'est un
jour je suis foule toute façon je
pourrai toujours recommandé d'autres
personnes tu vois que je sais très
compétent quoi au cas où peut toujours
me katsas a jamais ça mange pas de pain
d'écrire on voit un message c'est le
fait ça le fait pas c'est pas un souci
mais cris vous voulez c'est pas trop dur
de trouver fab libye sûr que j'espère
comme vous avez un message blessure
faibli sur twitter me trouvais sur
instagram chercher sur facebook vous
allez sur le site de la fédération
française des échecs vous trouvez mon
nom fait clic droit dans le mondial va
ce mail de dans cette joie parce que je
connais le jem et adrien demuth la wii
je paie bravo à tous les français je les
connais d'échec c'est un petit milieu
donc même les gens pas français revient
tu les connais mais donald a fait
détourne ensemble tu as joué en équipe
en centralisant santa fe plein de trucs
et si d'actu gâteau maquis quand tu es
plutôt nul 2 échecs mais que tu aimes
bien tu penses que votre combien within
9 2 mètres par heure mais en fait ça
dépend de toi tu es finances 2010 quel
jeu on n'aura pas la même réponse à
quelqu'un qu'il y ait dix mille par mois
parfois quelqu'un de gagner 5000 par
mehdi minne où tu vas c'est ça dépend en
fait ça dépend de toi combien tu mets
porte et loisirs en fête
si tu aimes les est fier des restos et
les gens vivront une claque beaucoup
pour ses restos toi tu as truc vous
annoncez raisonnable d'être tellement
d'acheter jolie montre des thèmes bien
de faire du pied de six mois jean ça
c'est ta life
donc ce que tu es prêt à mettre porter
loisirs doit être en adéquation avec tes
revenus est ce que tu peux y mettre
salut tout tout qui est la dh par touba
fois pour tout je sais pas en tout cas
là je suis là produit au loup qui est
bien ou leur décapotable c'est très bien
dans leur décapotable tu veux l'acheter
être que la louve est très bas voire les
moyens et parfois aussi on est pas mal
de pauvres rêve tu peux gagner à
l'euromillions tu faisais de deux
montées intrus gagner plus travailler je
sais pas quand tu fais de beaux objets
de triche enfin au pire tu as bossé et
j'ai quelqu'un qui achète un livre et a
pas mal d'infos dans un livre c'est
moins interactifs qu'avec un court mais
je travaille tout seul ça peut être bien
faire tu vas sur alpha échec quelque
part ob trouvent les livres et bien quoi
mais quand on peut monter c'est un oui
mais ça enfin ce sont l'économie mais en
fait on n'est pas obligés de tout
attendre de l'état quoi enfin je fais
pas ci macron il a son mot à dire en
fait sur les salaires de compagnies
privées quelque part bien livré qui
parfois voilà les professionnels il ya
la kalach mais compliqué suivre mais le
professionnel facile à lire très simple
très bien voilà vivo porte très bien
c'était un très bon vendeur que je
compte prendre comme agent le tri
minéraux pourcentage ici dataco tu m'as
clique soient un peu fâchés avec la voix
soit dépend de quel club il ya si tu
veux juste prendre ta licence à faire
des tournois je pensais pas très cher
fatah des cotisations dans les clubs ce
n'est pas les caisses étaient pas où tu
habites sur conclave à paris c'était pas
le même prix que ça détiennent tient
donc au sein
sinon est ce que vous pouvez faire des
lectures isolé ou la française de fab
ouais il ya les dvd bien sûr ils
devaient les faits il ya plein de trucs
en fait tu peux prendre des cours
individuels de faire des cours
collectifs cuir des stages genre ouais
moi je montrais bien une idée là c'est
de faire un petit groupe de travail si
suis personne à partir de la rentrée on
sera moins chère des cours individuels
et par niveau supposé outre les trucs
adapté mais je sais pas tu vois je peux
pas te dire que tu dois mettre combien
chance à chacun son budget et ça ça sans
raison de chacun des jeux peut pas juger
mais tu peux pas dire assez cher à se
cacher sa mort en paix et france-comté
truc box aqmi ont attaqué samedi et
belinelli tu me trouvais est-ce que j'ai
une méthode de saint pour apprendre la
notation des cases s'exercer sur czech
comme mes parents peuvent-ils pas tu
t'habitues mais les gracieuses comme il
est bien content loi est en fait tu sais
tu te débrouilles le nom une case genre
3d les cliques et ding liguo 6 0 3
elle peut prétendre être sacré champion
du monde il peut prétendre je peux pas
dire qu'il soit favorite pour l'avoir ou
quoi mais là en tout cas à mi parcours
est en tête des candidats
donc en fait s'il fait une deuxième
partie de tournoi équivalente à la
première il ya quand même des chances de
se qualifier à une fois quand evans
champion du monde quand même n'était pas
loin donc oui peu près temps voilà c'est
pas fait de l'histoire des candidats
bien évidemment et puis même j'ôte en
finale contre cap seine s'est pas fait
de le battre mais auquel était louis
gosse toujours présent et c'est loin
d'être nul comme chance c'est reparti
voilà ils sont en standby c'est pas tout
annuler et c'est en stand by on sait pas
qu'on sait et les joueurs sa femme à
essars partie connais avec les blancs
gontrie fans c'est du bullet donc ça va
ça va chauffer dégage reprend les
questions chatte après c'est un petit
système col très gluant joué par les
jeunes viennent donc être estimé sky
c'est ça avec les blancs peuvent faire
ces quatre aussi s'ils veulent tous
hibou fluence et 5 un jour où ira-t-on
foulée 2 c'est très symétriques on verra
les blancs qui ont sûrement un peu
cavalier en cinq ans peut être les
premiers à venir s'installer au centre
mais bon on l'a tous les échanges
intéressants
c'est ça le truc tu changes la structure
change tout très compliqué comme
structure qui ont donc les marques ont
repris tour c'est à jouer peut-être pas
au quidam 7 les noirs jouent pour le
contrôle de la caisse de 4 en face ils
sont pas quelques fois ci justement est
ok tous rêvent d un les blancs
centralise caillou 4 on en parle et ça y
est là il est là il rayonne lui de
l'échiquier et j'aime déjà pas trop mal
mais normand et ouverture sans trop
d'ambitions pour un puits et la 40
secondes déjà c'est pas bon signe ça
veut dire qu'il n'est pas très habitué
aux bulles est
ouais mais en fait elle était longue
depuis le début du match et repris ça
peut te payer un fief à jouer bon le
seul truc positif que je vois pour les
noirs c'est le pion à 6 tu vois ça vit
ça bloque un peu la torah vite mais pour
l'instant les plutôt pas mal d'affaires
du fou mais un point je veux dire point
d'un bep 2 dé petits plans sournois
comme ça quoi vous pouvez les deux
attaques le pion au f5 pour tout déformé
savent bien faire les cases noires non l
affaire
5à les cas les c4 le fou et attaquer
fort recul mais je serai bien du foin
franchement qu'elle fait d'amd d'otago
qui invalide un c3 wemmel le faire mieux
alors ouais elle fait donc ses 3 est
encore plus maligne quoi ces tirs la
main aux gens d'éviter web on doit
passer trois c'est sûr qu'ils veulent
faire voilà tu as eu cinq j'imagine et
qu'elle va être fou rire aussi
c'est pas tip top ou la f6 c'est très
fragile très très très fragile édifice
noir tu perds des services de qualité à
tout moment sur 17 déjà s'est fait peur
ils sont juste tour des deux tours d un
autour c'est au tour des deux séries
s'ajoutent les monceaux s'arrête dès
maintenant et pour les noirs se tourne
au vinaigre
ça tourne à la sauce soja je dirais même
un peu aigre-douce intégrale de c'est
alors bon à l'as cannes 3 secondes
contre 12,1 ça peut le faire
ça peut le faire pour où on va voir
tourner de londres auquel prend part à
nouveau versé 4 mais ça va hélas elle a
au moins à l'aide
l enlever les problèmes sur la grande
diagonale pour ses 8 points 5 dame prend
kaki variant ses quatre meilleures
structures heureusement les blancs sont
français avec les morts quand même hein
tu peux changer d'âme des deux titans
qui échoue voilà elle va monter son roi
fin elle a bien stade et blanc les
blancs sont ok les gens sont ok mais pas
de danger bâche et pas les biens sont
sur 15 blanche mais c'est trop dur les
attaques et de chance mais bon ça va en
fait enfin je sais pas trop par
contrôler les projets primés du tout
aelia est l'heureux s'aperçoit père pour
najwa zain diane sa super pole je vais
me faire comprendre 5g symbole là c'est
fini ça n'importe wayne aurait donné à
chaque fois comme ça c'est à quel
horaire est bien orienté avec alisation
au score dès la joueuse chinoise
bon faut quand même finir mais bon
normalement il va faire mais je suis
même pas plus sur ce gagnant ça seront
f4f de et tu suis le roi la position
donc par trois mais voilà cette fois 6
jan tu attends font-ils
bah oui mais voilà bah oui on passe pas
ça va faire nul à massy
mathieu terrible terrible terrible
d'être finale attend elle s'était du gué
quoi battre tous les moments c'est une
horreur ouais c'est histoire des casse
conjugué kwata f4 et f-22 f 5 e 5 e 3 et
tu dois tourner dans le bon sens ou dans
ce cas s attend à la fois juste pour
voir maintenant comment il s'est fait
parce que moi je trouve ça je sais pas
trop où exactement mais là ça va
là ça va là où 2 ouais là aussi sans
patrie russe 5e 55 on a dit que c'était
le 2 et le 5 6 3 dans tous les ans des
deux mondes et 3 oui ok c'est vrai
encore de tout accord détroit ça c'est
la faute c'est la faute
voilà ton fiel avec un prendre les
caisses conjugales ouais
la veille un apprenti conjugaison ouais
ben t'es tout ça alors quatre cavaliers
ou ses cadres des trois hockey des six
bons et vous n'êtes pas refuser
quadrillage 3 pour imiter h6 pareil qui
viendra pas non plus j'ai cinq personnes
doivent assurer qu'ils découragent fouet
trois développement parce qu'elle va
faire foi aussi symétrique à l'épreuve
sera ok dang tran et ouais où elle joue
tout le temps avec son fond ces quatre
ans fait elle aime bien ouais trimark
d'amd cette bombe a du coup elles
attendent d'être grand roque le grand
rush des 5 g 4 2 ils vous envoient mère
migrants cassette mais auquel assistent
voilà très bien en tchèque f4 weapon je
me reprends que ce qui est des dames à 7
c'est un peu relou mais peut-être c'est
pas si grave parce que tu en es salam de
17 était pas mal aux dames à 7 c
bougrement bien joué olala terrible
les perdus non mais nathan hale et du
coup qu'un jeu les hôtels journal
j'étais juste sous le choc de choquer
ouais voilà c'est choquant c'est
terrible je sais mais moi aussi je me
suis fait peur la bad à mattia bat
voiture
forcément quand on est dans l'émotion du
moment quand même la demi finale quoi
quatrième grand prix donc ou qui peut
peut-être encore se qualifier et la
partie très important pour elle donc je
pense sa dernière partie donc connais on
doit absolument égaliser
sinon besson radio qui avait trop élevé
pour être sûr que vous hésitez toujours
là quoi parce qu'il est en santé c'était
un peu mou et tout le tchad puis la
poule nakouh vous sur tout et vous êtes
sur la cua vous vivez bien c'est comme
pour les huîtres qui faisait figure du
tuner fait sursauter les huîtres la
turquie ne bouge pas tu manges pas alors
du coup cette position là qu'est ce qui
se passe est aussi c'est un peu chiant
qui a aidé de quelques 4 j'aime pas trop
mal les blancs car peut-être f4 salaires
fort bien joué qu'à hd 4k et des quatre
qui arrive tout le monde qui convergent
vers oran sur ou qui se fait égaliser
peut-être on va reconvertir
c'est pas failli arriver en plus mais je
fais mon thé à la main pour pas que
j'aie cul de la bouche tu es à la vente
mais bas à la cnsa du voile ou du show
est non c'est du faux c'est pas du vrai
puisque flemme en fait vous voyez j'ai
je suis tellement flemmarde j'ai acheté
genre des capsules de thé tu vois genre
comme
captieux non what else to sah paysanne
ok c'est si c'est intéressant ce qu'elle
fait l'essai de démolir le centre et
noirs les blancs à falloir trouver des
bons coups peut-être d'un match 4 damage
6 dur à dire mais là c'est qu'ils
parlent de nous tourner un peut-être
pour quel poison et tout ça mais il veut
bouffer ramé saddam en verser 3 verset 2
ne se laisse pas pas compte et vous fait
la ou les cahiers des 400 dessins ok ça
sort des infos
j'ai pas aimé le client point f4 la la
ça ça pue ça plus grave est le père
comprend des saints mais bon dames 3 f4
savage est déchiré je pense méprendre à
l'avant kg parce que j'ai raté encore en
tête rien mais bon je viens madame tulle
ac d'ahmed sais tu le sais tout c'est
bizarre de faire ça au point parfois pop
à celle d'hier apple et aux balles
réelles la même geste historique cette
taxe est allé thorax est oui là les six
prochains mois
pas mal pas mal
l'égalisation à mal les mains elle aura
quatre combats la mam alabama mais quoi
sache pas encore ou quoi hélas sa jambe
il reste une minute quarante minutes la
dernière sa dernière partie décisive
trop bien très bien dans quelle voiture
aux origines on nous fait pas ce à quoi
tu ça s'est passé nul cette ouverture
bon ça c'est solide j'aime passer par de
mélo ensuite baissé lula j'ai enfin je
connais pas mon nom en fait t'as pas
fait un tel choix de choisir les bleus
en ont blessé trois dans la pétrole soit
tu rentres vingt quatre cavaliers soit
là dedans mais ça en fait ça ressemble à
une berlinoise inversée bon je suis un
fou fait 10 à fond on ne voit que ce
n'est pas une tare h pour fils des ans
tout revin ok bon ben on peut faire chez
pas quoi kg 6 voilà bien joué faut pas
jouer trop doucement et la 44 secondes
50 des possibles nos rites si tu te
trouves que je crie trop et tu es invité
à quitter la junior
aucun souci tu sois belge et pas nourrir
ils trouvent que je crie trop mais c'est
le principe quoi l info de l'armée pour
vous verrez que l'autre oui à tort sinon
ça sert à rien alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe
attac b2 n'ont pas tout à fait mais
presque ces trois blocs un peu aller
qu'à l'étranger 3 je pense à si on prend
pour prendre 3 2 me prendrait trois
dames preuve trop quel point cette fois
ou c3 où j'ai 3 avril si on prend des
trois amateurs
pas de chance et enfin des choses non
mais dommage grave je suis patient tu as
mis ensemble ça fait leur parcours pour
des villes telles affaires je pense
voilà takla d'am-dam e2 peut-être bessie
smith un petit coup comme ça pour pas
donner l dame est là quelles mesures
étaient de pions les blues perdent flou
mais ça joue sajou dis juste qu'on
trompe trente-et-une on verra si j'ai 5
elle s'engouffre avec élégance je vais
apprendre se tient ce soir mon psy mais
bon ok ça jouait seul souci moore et là
c'est une maman elle conte patrice colin
qui tremble c'est la partie décisive
ok faut aussi citer pourront s'échanger
de partout les gens ont peut-être te
faire un coup comme ces cinq à un moment
pour des bars et pour le non et les
change pas les tours chinon maintenant
j'aime bien tam g6 télésat web on
s'habitue fixe il a quoi cinq bombes
n'ont alors pas fixée même si ce qu'elle
jette un oeil sur le pion la dame
l'attaqué bleue farine en finale comme
toi et bouge et quatre en fait on l'a
pas laissé l'occasion kébé vite
ok peut-être qu'on peut bouffer dames 3e
5 dépensé 5 à la phase 6 est d'amener à
la fin d'un v6 des champions auront ok
c'est pas mal c'est compliqué mais les
troubles en france à prendre possession
de la position de cinq idées bien à ces
cinq hommes condamnés comme m6 à calais
ces cinq là du coup d'andré à taux fixe
qui ont accueilli les voilà ça va super
bien ça kaka à 5 bon bah oui voilà c'est
un pion quoi d'albicy sockeye à 30%
ça tourne au vinaigre pour des joueuses
chinoises et chez courageuse passer une
si bonne idée sur échec ça c'est pas si
mal aura peut-être des fouaces trois ans
pour faire pas mal attention tu fais un
truc comme h5 calella kaleva okalys 300
ça pue ça le faut bouffer façon et ses
chaudes à mettre un carillon au beffroi
qui arrive ça va faire très mal dans ma
lutte à l'aube ont joué ou g4g sa fusée
voilà et là je trouve c'est fini aïe aïe
aïe
parce que de mettre un avocat elle va
bouffer d'avocats c'est si beau vraiment
bien joué sauf que ça marche pas mais
c'était bien joué comme on aimerait
tentative est ok vous ferais quoi la
gagner
[Musique]
le thème le thème est fini tu es ma came
up arriver un très joli match ce bon
trimestre
inculpé aujourd'hui à paris malgré tout
qu'une femme de times je me dois de nous
alors malinois finalistes très bonnes
joueuses enchaîne sur plus et donc
maintenant la seconde légalement ses
moyens même si nous battons sonné pour
que la fiche de finale mais en fait
c'est très rigolo parce que parce que
ils entendent ils ont tant de simone moi
j'ai pas besoin mais toi tu l'entends
pas fou fois ci c'est très bien mais
quoi bah je vois je préfère traducteur
et où j'entends pas je peux tu vois je
préfère le nelson monfort de pièces
comme sahbi sournois si j'ai pas le
retour sont 200 avant que je peux pas
l'avoir tout sera maintenant je sais moi
comme vous voulez oui la touche ceux qui
disent aime bien ça vous avez commenté
les enfants avec marco belle pas proposé
non je crois qu'on peut les enfants en
fait c'est différent les enfants c'est
sur pied ce qu'ils n'ont même s'il ya un
truc un peu en lien qui est ce comme
j'ai pas trop quoi c'est quand même pas
la même chose ces deux mondes différents
alexandra une photo de dinars ça j'ai
peut être une photo de botteur est là et
c'est quoi le truc avec sandra beauvais
c'est ouais je veux des chiots aussi je
me tenais je tenais d'aidé qui arrive
résultat si on prend pas ce qui se passe
il a eu ce christian aid a mal géré et
muta pas mais taper mes limites je vais
mettre mes limites dans le chat aussi
attend ce qu'elle a rien
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui veut dire le spike sachant
que 90 % des partis que je jouais à
quesnoy roulé blanc ouvre avec des caps
au système de l'ombre pourrait-on avoir
un jour une master class anti l'ombre
bas peut-être je sais pas en fait on
voulait faire une série vidéo avec kev
là dessus un peu comme pour le dvd avec
la ddt mais en plus courts quoi bien sûr
donc avoir plus sinon master class on
verra mais l'a pour l'instant ça flashe
fois que la prochaine avec maso avant
d'échanger espagnols étaient deux trois
trucs prévu mais après pourquoi pas mais
je crois qu'on avait déjà donné une
petite indication pour comment je vais
contre croyait plus de chez moi mais ça
dépend déjà ce que tu joues avec les
nord première question c'est quoi ton
répertoire normale sur des cas de ces
quatre jours son genre nims au destin
dieng qu'une faible de slaves
je sais pas ça change j'aime beaucoup
c'est important et après on va faire un
truc en adéquation avec mon choix et
jérémy c'est moi en fait en direct d'un
piètre c'est moi on direct en live moi
bah oui en direct terrific je serai
jamais assez fier de ses genoux en fait
je n'ai en fait j'avais pas capté que je
t'assure prêtons et sachent qu à tabriz
à shiraz ton message
avaya karachi est réservée avec tout le
monde à l'écart je sais pas pourquoi
pourquoi en guise d acheter
je sais pas moi c'est pour troller je
sais pas ce qu'il fait bon usage ils
arrivent tous en fait la ville arrive
tous nous partons à l écart gay et oui
pas ta foi j'ai en direct en zone c
c'est écrit en direct et sud en tchat
aïe croquer un autre que macky créer
n'importe quoi reggae n'importe quoi on
sait pas trop quoi des lettres mais qui
n'a pas trop de sens se disent donc
n'importe quoi ce qui fait le miroir
asphyxie g5 forcément tu vois des
problèmes même très bien raison les
albanais tous se sont passées mais moi
aussi du coup mais bon moi dd on se
garde bien je regrette un présage
ça dépend lesquels on se marre ça dépend
ce que tu appelles pro c'est bon mais
les tout meilleurs mondiaux wii sont pas
se plaindre
et puis y est prête en a qui ont de
meilleurs fonds d'autres et puis voilà
ça dépend mais en général c'est pas un
marché ne fait pas échec pour devenir
millionnaire de passe pas trop le délire
abat sa scission
ouais bon grand en fait et c'est pas
qu'on est un manque de contenu gratuit
que tu peux pas d'un mois selon moi tu
peux pas permettre de demander aux gens
de payer un abo alors que j'aurais ya
tellement de contenus gratuits partout
que fin ça me paraît déplacé en fait
limite de nom mais ça dépend la qualité
de ton produit et à oui mais moi même la
qualité de ton croizier enfin josé ruf
sipa jarre temps tu fais un truc très
spécialisés des heures sur un sujet
c'est autre chose
mais le truc en fait c'est que c'est
déjà trop spécialisées pour beaucoup de
gens en fait le truc gratuit bas étage
va dire déjà l'autre est suffisant et il
est donc voilà après du coup ça demande
beaucoup de fois en fait doubler un site
on va contre les jarres créer une appli
ses trente quarante cinquante mille
euros de les envoyer faudra les
rentabiliser pour qu'il fasse un truc
très solide parce que ça doit être lui
d'avoir un truc protéger financièrement
magnifique volée les données
utilisateurs puissent te faire hacker
taggia cet investissement brabant de
revenir sur tes frais savait toujours
des gens achètent c'est juste pas
rentable en général mais ma saison et je
pense que les gens la plupart du temps
ils veulent pas acheter
je vois très bien quand le moi je vous
propose un stage il est pas remplie
cantal et le vidéo dvd de vlad qui a un
truc excellent il n'y a pas eu un nombre
de ventes extraordinaires vous dire wesh
chaque chaque vidéo sur le stream à l
art est de dix mille vu tu peux dire oui
tu ne tueras 10% de la piste chez toi
loin de là non très loin de ça pas du
tout du port sont donc en fait c'est
beaucoup de boulot ou un truc pas
forcément super rentable alors après tu
voir des gens qui pensent de l'argent en
l'air je le fais repos qu'il en soit
même pas rentable c'est possible si tu
veux le faire bah c'est pas si loin
non ma fait j'aime bien le principe des
tweets justement c'est que les jambes à
y regarder c'est gratos et c'est
franchement il aime bien le contenu et
qui sont capables de sponsoriser le
contenu bah voila il sponsorise s'il
veut comme eux
j'aime bien j'aimais ce principe en fait
je préférais plus plus à vous fournir du
contenu gratuitement et puis c'est les
gens veulent te soutenir ben est qu'il
se tienne
oui mais ce rire c'est peut être deux
contenus différents tubes vert du truc
gratuit
oui il va me dire bonjour elle parce que
je connais la chaîne de cave qui est
gratuit depuis 2012 mérite en quoi c'est
à dire qu'il ya eu des je pense des
milliers de vidéos gratuites en fait si
un jour tu as un contenu payant tu peux
dire oui bon c'est que c'est autre chose
en fait tu fais pas la même chose
évidemment pas par faire le truc et des
gratuits en payant la plus loin plus
poussée c'est aussi possible mais mais
ça marche moins bien c'est que ça marche
a clairement moins bien donc c'est pas
si simple ça paraîtrait logique de créer
une plate forme mais ça marche suivi sa
joie ouais
désolé ça joue mais en fait j'ai raté
parce que parce que gégé pas quitté
désolée la maire
je suis toujours ou ouais voilà non je
n'ai pas quitté la bonne celle de zoom
en fait c'est juste ça désolé les gars
je doute qu'il y ait essayé avec les
échecs en vidéo bas tout à fait
s'appelle tôt marché pourtant le
continue d'être très bonne qualité tu
avais trois grands maîtres qui faisait
des vidéos des chèques des cours mais
c'était pas cher l'abonnement mais
s'exprime plus en fait le truc c'était
fiasco alors que ça vient pas du fait
que les cours sont nuls c'était très
bien passé non pas du coup tu n'étais
pas très bien que c'est pas vendu en
tout cas le contenu chaque était bien
moi je peux te dit tout d'accord avec
toi tous fermés
parce que j'estime pas faire de la
manche mais manche je trouve que tout
simplement c'est les gens qui veulent
proposer un contenu gratuit et pourquoi
pas les laisser faire ce qu'ils veulent
en fait je je je je je pense pas que ça
doit être vue comme de la manche parce
que moi enfin j'ai jamais jamais obligé
qui que ce soit je fais la manche a
donné mais j'ai jamais objets qu'il soit
amené à me donner de l'argent quand je
dire je fais ça pour mon plaisir je fais
ça parce que j'aime faire ça et c'est je
mange quoi je comprends pas trop dire
que c'est de la manche je suis pas
d'accord avec ça tout désolé mais voilà
vajra la normale mais voir sacrifier un
petit fou projet 6 des familles mais
j'ai des douaniers qui l'ait pas fait
plus proche soit le coup d'avoir fait
faux bond à 7 parce que cavaye été cloué
mai mais du coup tu t'es un filtre est
partout mais bon là ça peut claquer faut
calculer un peu je fais ressent pas
moins le calcul paul joue des coups bas
mais c'est quoi manger 6 quand même
c'est du temps investi intéressant sista
gagne ça gagne mais voilà il sait gagnes
pas tu as encore deux minutes contre une
pendant que c'est pas grave mais ça
valait le coup de d'analysé pas ça tu as
gagné au mans avec les blancs fin mine
de rien tu m'as tu pas au rendez vous et
honte au mans tours et fluide j'imagine
un blindé un peu de cheval empaillé du
jeu un pour le blanc
je comprends pas pourquoi on continue
sur ce sujet tout petit se répondent et
sur le fait que oui d'accord mais je
dirai ce que ceux qui font la manche et
propose du contenu gratuit éducatif
non mais faisant bonne conscience quoi
je donnais bah ouais merci merci et owen
un peu de travail au maroc est il pas
méchant tout l'art est vrai c'est ça
m'énerve un peu en fait
bon après on peut tous être vu comme un
des gens qui font la manche
on travaille enfin sa défense dépend des
gens quoi mais j'estime que je me bouge
enfin
en tout cas j'estime que je fais pas
rien de mes journées j'estime que je
croyais vraiment pas mal en fait donc
chacun chacun y voit sa commune iv un
niveau je trouve pas ça très juste
forcément de dire tu fais la manche
pendant un mois j'aurais bien fait que 4
clément oui ça il ya deux coups vous
tous et 2,4 dézinguer un peu tout peut
faire dès le 5e faire des choses et à
moi
ok hélas elles leurs ouailles un peu
intéressants bah ouais savons qu'il est
là je crois qu'on s'est retrouvé là mais
bon il ya en tout cas ça va porter
fatalis et bongrand qui par la chaîne
vitrine dans sa cave jusqu'à cap juste
mais beaucoup d'intervenants et moi je
suis souvent là ou quoi mais c'est lui
il fait ce qu'il veut de super c'est lui
qui l'a créé tout le mérite lui revient
mais aussi beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'énergie dessus ça parle d'argent
énormes la guerre non mais tous tout
oppose l'argent après ce normal qu'en
fait on avec du travail on dit tout
travail mérite salaire
avec maintenant toute façon il ya
beaucoup de contenu gratuit
les gens s'habituent pichot quand même
des gens habitués au club ces tarifs
très bas par rapport à ce que tu fais en
indépendant il faut jamais oublier que
les gens qui travaillent en indépendants
comme ça tu paies des charges et des
taxes des machins un patin c'est comme
ça à dresser un coup c'est la vie quoi
comme tout un coup à bricoler alors est
ce qu un terrain pas tout noir mais par
contre est la faute des périodes dans
ces menaces et ça commence déjà su de la
prend à partie ok baba dur battant
voyait pas très bien le noir un manteau
rigueur non à droite et malgré ça tu est
peut-être pire la partie mais alors elle
a fait à 3 ok on sait avant que
petrossian de la bastidienne
en général les blancs font ça pour faire
dame ses deux avocats trouve que là en
fait
alexandra elle a joué de manière à
éviter ça avec kelly au cap occuper la
case et donc les blancs n'ont pas poussé
si facilement pousse à te se développent
et blanc fou des trois des cinq rapports
on a déjà vu plus ou moins cette
ouverture il pas si longtemps tu as déjà
alexandre adler
tu as déjà les domaines c'est très
précieux pour la troisième place
ouais alors j'ai essayé des ducs en
général ça change pas trop d'ouvertures
ben je vais essayer de remettre le truc
parce qu'à chaque fois en fait à chaque
fois ça donne quoi je rêve pages
devraient inventer un programme pour que
pour faire quoi pour quel jeu font qu'il
ya des gens qui quittent leur réunion
zoom ça reste sur la même personne quand
même
ok bon à position est foutu grosse
tension centrale les blancs peut
peut-être faire un truc comme des
français 5 b process inquiets bessin qui
ma foi on s'attend ouverte on fout des
deux ne sera pas affaiblie et en
appelant seulement actions passées c'est
peut-être au maire de réagir je ne sais
pas qui ça peut faire d'autre je
pencherai sur 100 ha - du divan
je sais pas ce que ça vaut ici par an
cette position mais j'en ai besoin c'est
intéressant
dcb synchrone aux médias aux médias
alexandra et puis après on mettra
remettra ça rhin pour pour les fans je
sais que c'est très important
connaissent a donc comme est déjà chef
queen et ensuite on mettra le pape wengé
déjà oui je trouve pas les voir soir
c'est de participer
bon on a bien investi que le salsifis
quoi vos rebelles ok donc elle a fait
les coups que je pense être intéressant
bon ben si ça l'est vraiment ou pas mais
c'est mon téléphone tu vois quand des
fois je dis ok il croit que j'y parle
bon après je fabrique parle de shopping
mais bon attention bombe à s'évaporer
bande am prend des cinq qui suit on va
l'apprendre 2d du coup m'aide à me
prendre cette dame des cinq échecs dames
3 f3 puis tu es bien pardon non pas je
prendrais pas toi je parle des autres
châteaux n'arrête ce débat cette
élection s'il vous plaît que les gens de
moins de demande pas de l'argent en fait
on s'en fout donc peu juste passer à
autre chose peut-être
voilà merci ouais je suis bon je suis
pas trop ce qui se passe à ce débat de
manière un peu
voilà merci véhémente
voilà
ok cool du coup le tchad n'a plus jamais
rien dire non mais jamais en jet privé
plus c'est fini tu dois tuer à vide avec
ce jeu est stoppé net quoi j'ai stoppé
net dans leur élan
tu l'as toupet ouais ouais bon la
position suisse bien pour le monde a
besoin de plus de preuves à la raison et
à l'état de répression censure qui
arrive je ne pensais pas qu'il y aurait
un jour ce terrible des têtes risquent
fait mal au coeur du bon hockey
j'aime bien avec kate j'aime bien on
peut en parler de menthe et l'abolition
de la taxe et 4 après on attaque un peu
à droite à gauche
la sara elle est très très bien est-ce
qu'on peut vendre la gamme de sarah mais
oui mais voilà voilà ça c'est dur est
question que la liberté d'expression est
dans ma tasse de thé et je suis en train
de la boire donc vous allez faire quoi
qu'est-ce que à 5 peut-être des jouets
sera en fait le design n'a pas été conçu
pour voir les deux joueuses
malheureusement donc c'est pas moi qui
ai fait le design donc l aragon sinon on
peut pas avoir les deux tout avait bien
aimé faire le design
alors je vais c'est trop compliqué pour
moi sont pas une âme de designers non
pas du tout ouais bof c'est pas si
simple de gagner ça pour l'instant j'ai
pas vu sarah mais vu l'engouement pour
vous est-ce qu'on peut la mettre
aulas mais je n'en peux plus et salue
zico tu arrive au bon moment et le chat
qui trollent ou alors ils veulent pas
mais dans tous les cas le chat est
chiant je sors c'est trop du peuple
c'est une partie d'échecs mois rancart
mais oui voilà trop les contrôler comme
ce à quoi bon vent du côté inquiète oui
même le chat en pleine forme
en fait voilà sont le débat qu'en fait
que chess queen ou sarah moi j'aime bien
ça parce que cela gêne et surtout de
choses que nous sommes très bonne
question n'apportent je m'étais pas
décidé je je les deux sont plutôt sympas
sarah la jeunesse walt et jesse
winchester in clichy quoi ouais vas y
les arguments de part et d'autre mais si
vous parlez pas physiquement mettre des
échecs
la bomba chile fabricant du tout je sais
pas pour qui je suis costaud et là des
orions voilà alors à l'égard d'un procès
quatre soit vous souhaitez à la france
inquiète sa valeur possible échec des
changes tas d'options but en finale deux
tours
normalement c'est pas si mal mais qui a
des arguments revanche nrj qui parle
quoi des joueuses et oui mais laquelle
je sais pas c'est moi qui déjà les
arguments qui voit les ont repris qua
non ça va entre hal et je crois que la
question allait vite répondu
pourquoi alors faire j'ai trop fait il
peur celle où paraît changé d'âme je
comprends pas tu peux jeune femme deux
tours avec d'options de plus tu regardes
les la forêt justice je fais au nom bon
sportif et matete
c'est mérité g3 et tu veux pas de faire
mater là quand même j'ai trois tu
ouais mais bon les dom vayssette des
machins ça reprend tout rendent à
l'achat pourquoi tu as fait ce à quoi tu
n'as pas besoin et a deux fils avec
d'options plus de gagner mallinger 3 tu
vois non c'est pas celle ci stor.e sur
sa radio comme gagner mais je te dis pas
que j'ai mal plus pourquoi c'est vrai
que c'est le boîte ils seraient
invectivés haine de soi aller s'aérer de
spammer avec tes smiley quoi voit pas et
c'est très bien ça donne quoi tu as un
bot
bonjour toi pour l'instant il a banni
personne n'a eu envie de sneijder
comprendre mais là mais toi tu peux en
fait parce que tu es moins d'eau tombent
des trucs dsk qui arrivent et g4 le
peloton pleutres alors moi je peux
battre n'importe qui il accorde moi le
bot ont fait favoritisme en effet un bon
retour aux six attaques la dame de fer
d'albi 7 sont que les hommes c'est pas
rien quand même
donc là c'est nul c'est mieux que ce que
tu fais pas partie il à rabat
est-ce que tu pas bonne le baht a
peut-être peut-être que le jeu s'est pas
fait c'est fait par me le sac c'est une
très bonne question car je propose un
combat dans l'octogone au bâti j'aurais
dit poutine
il va beaucoup moins faire le malin de
la routine tiens prends toi ça déjà
voilà il plus rien trois bombes allaient
tous ces cinq là toujours cette option
de plus ça va finalement céder jamais
rapportera qui file à tout à l'heure
le match encore pour une bonne heure tu
reviens dans son mouvement ouais parce
qu'elle attend il reste neuf de 50 donc
plus 30 minutes + 10 minutes + 6 minutes
à chaque fois entre des matches mais
voilà bonheur il faut les envies des
banquets cd decca qui doublerait des
trucs comme ça ben taïba 3 qui dit quoi
vraiment rendement caisse je pensais
c'est mon préféré
ça fait partie de mes motos demi pour
voir la réaction de du boccia zamel
tendance à faire fumer le robot polymère
ferait z ça c'est pour ça c'est bon ça
allait je sais pas et damas dans le
cadre de me casser bien ça dans mes
quatre manades tours 8
ça leur fille mila hatin dernier
dernière et des cheveux ça vaut mais tu
peux tenter d'avocate ses trois tours 8
ces deux ans d'amour reprendra mais puis
il bombe même état d'âme et 6 échecs par
contre il a sorti en 2004
ouais ouais de me kate c'est fini de me
kate se finisse par voir
bon après même genre parce que voilà on
a quoi quoi quoi à laquelle puis voilà
qui est plus un truc mais la fessée de
un peu vite qu'un hacker nord parce que
ça souhaite qu'il fallait faire ce à
quoi qu'ils aient pas de défense juste
c'était mon parti vite c'est d'eux que
totalement naturel g18 totalement
naturel pas pu répondre oui oui oui oui
oui tu rêves alors c'est quoi cet
espagnol du jour pour soir qui chaque
fois nous ont fait de nouvelles elle
joue le style mix différent
c'est quoi ça passé ça avait fait des
sites avec à 6 ouais bon vouloir de
danse avec kelly et si ce geste juste et
rock ouï naturel si celui ci se voit à
kayes mali connaît c'est un expert de
des espagnols et jusqu'à tomber un sens
à ce 4e et partira sans voix et puis on
le pirate ship ercis j'ai passé
intéressant moi je trouve ça intéressant
chaque fois 2 / h 4 de réagir par
hachette comme ça sur agen confesse j'ai
cinq missions plus rien et tu es
tranquille
voilà c'est ça sa luge et rami vote de
britney spears ayoub soyez beat again tu
vois mon coup mais reconnu qu'en fait la
à la blague à la blague je trouve
curieux que alors bon bah ouais c'est
pas grand chose mais c'est pas la partie
du siècle elle apprend d'amour apprend à
damas trois voilà quand même on garde
les dames on n'est pas plus autre dame
cécile suggéré l'idée cannes ça bouge et
7 ok mais peut-être bon gage 5e partira
la malice attaque essayons ouais ouais
ouais vous le devez à des e mails et pas
la boule de l'ade près de 29 balles a
surtout esclaves en fait
j'ai collecté 9 des 10 compagnies qui
t'appelle fabricant pardon il t'avait le
fabricant le t9 de dick au hockey parce
que y'a fab fabricants et skyrock c'est
comme une espagnole mais pour les
formative de quoi est ce qu'une catalan
c'est comme une espagnole lui pour les
indépendantistes indépendant enfin il va
pas du tout oui mais heureusement
espagnole et catalane c'est pas avec les
mêmes colères n'irait ben ouais savoir
c'est vrai si c'est rouge et jaune les
deux quoi ok on l'a fait h57 au pradet
h5 définitivement au tout à fait aller
pour les noirs le derrière et le réel
mannequin chez rock rock tour d un aller
retour des mini itx partie de fond de
court quoi ça remet la balle les
échanges très très bombée trajectoires
arrondies et joueuses de prennent pas de
risques non mais je crois que c'est
juste égal il fait un peu ça s'est
échauffé et à bas mais j'ai mis la clim
ça va je ne fais que de télécommande
mais pas de l'aqim des pages m par sa
devanture jeu la messe dans la vie mais
devra je réponds pas question ainsi
posant que soit dressée à moi ben qui
d'autre n'avoir à quoi sert un blâme et
jamais fait autant là on fait beaucoup
de beaucoup de versions différentes mais
n'a vraiment jamais voilà c'est face à
nouveau leurs auteurs
ouais du coup quel âge c'est ok bon ça
défend devant le 5 principalement mes
bons sprints fourchette coiffer une
enfilade vous voulez voilà c'était pas
le coup du siècle un piège cette
cachette de ceux de linkedin
c'est dommage parce que mon fils est né
là-bas du coup bas soit plus quoi fini
quoi ouais
stop stop stop à dubout km il est navré
d'avoir atteint alors ça y est tu as ton
bon en fait je n'aurais pas dû dire ça
me fait suer parce que du coup là ils
ont chopé détruisons à méo et en fait ça
aurait fait chier du coup on va
l'appeler comme ça mais oui je vais
réagir
bref tu dois ban et j'ai pas encore les
droits des deux cas mais ça ne saurait
tarder bats toi comme il faut bien
méritée quoi cet ep n'est pas neuf
actuellement bien savoir l'allemagne et
tout ça pour ça qu'il ait jamais quand
je dis qu'il est vous qui pour ce que
fabrèges maintenant je dis qu'il est bon
c'est pas si je suis tellement naturel
tu vois j'ai l'habitude nous devions
réagir sinon si tu as juste voilà est-ce
qu'elle a un peu repris du poil de la
botte de nab et ouais non non non
un petit duvet inconvénient si tu vois
le duvet de l'abattement cette dame
sekkaki et prend bessèges ouais t'as
fait l'âme c'est wayne on sait bien que
les promesses à sa fonction j'ai quatre
bons mois ce qu'elle voit comme ces
quatre marins alors on voit que j'ai
fait trois dates en cheval quoi motiver
de la vie on se marre bien qu'un pion au
rendez vous ces cahiers des besoins de
plus avant ce procès de punir ces
mesdames bientôt jambes c'est ce sur
quoi bâtir notre parti au pouvoir du
caussels ses filles et deux parties une
partie une minute rend d'abord venir
alors dû attendre une minute à 29 4
nages avant d'habitation c'est la
moustache la buvette l'heure est
toujours à toujours c'était beau grain
jean ouais bah on est gâté beaucoup de
variétés nature a ils veulent vraiment
aller voir serbe là et je vais vous
faire ça moi aussi je suis très heureux
pour moi je vois pas mais c'est pas
grave j'ai offert cette concession ce
plaisir ça quel plaisir
alors attention les avait attaqués
égouttoir hawk est parti d'un bébé
quatre échecs on s'attend à un pic et
les deux quand même mais on va se faire
échanger les dames parce que qu'il prend
des deux sur les points 2 sur nous qui
prend des captiva qui va arriver donc
voilà il était de la merde en fait mort
faire ' gilles importants comme ce qui
est des deux qui est prévu dans le
programme court je suis bête comme un
pou en fait ce mois tous voient les
poussées superbe est quoi non mais
j'appuie sur la langue et au gel monde
est pareil ça marchait pas du coude a
répondu quoi mais wiki mails de peur ne
pense est batteur il voulait d'avoir
couvert elle savait pour les jours
d'audition près d un genre à casser 3
alors qu'alice et 3 je m'y attendais pas
pour plein de raisons déjà avons passé
quatre ans l'air pas trop ce qui a primé
admettons qu'ils un truc merkel prend
ces trois juste double les pions saeed
une bonne finale pour et noir mais du
coup pourquoi pas un vrai fin j'ai pas
compris
bref un bon tu te défonces pathé
structure se fera à trois tout à fait
pions et puis ok t'es ok tu feras h3
roger un machin tu vas y arriver ça peut
leur fille de la position d'une carte
baveux enfin bon il est encore là quand
tu veux dire c'est terrible
pierre et 6h bruch et samian pls bon je
sais que c'est pas de quoi je parle donc
pas m'attarder dessus et quoi moi wen en
rien ses joueurs de sainté c'est le goal
de synthèse l'histoire d'amour se
termine mal quand même il est au clap en
10 saisons et là ils ont mis à pied ou
quoi
je suis pas très content tu proteste
quelque part bon j'ai twitter je dis que
je te n'importe quoi et kamel qui est
l'histoire nord n'y a pas trop
d'histoires c'est jusque là très son se
fait quelques mois le club de temps
séparés parce qu'il a lu une histoire en
février au quai de la fosse bloqué de
base en fait c'est juste que le ppu elle
dans une entrée de synthés et décidé de
le faire souffler parce qu'ils aient pas
des matchs de ouf
bon c'est vrai il n'a pas apprécié et il
voulait pas être remplaçant il envoyait
son agent je passe ainsi de son père
c'est l'agent diop et sa décision
l'agent du joueur est allé dans les
médias fait comme des déclarations pas
sympa sympa tailler le club l'entraîneur
et ses aidants glauque et ça se fait pas
d'un gars ont vraiment fait soit tu dis
oui bon trop grave ce que tu affirmes
dégage soit tu fais que me l'on fait tu
t'en paurise il joue plus mais c'est pas
bon la saison s'arrête en plein cours de
route à cause du corona nous sont
reprochés il vient à l'entraînement tu
as tout se passe normalement
et puis là tout d'un coup tu m'as pied
mais en fait tu sois tu faisais sans
février quand il est le truc grave
soit tu laisses une deuxième chance
maintenant et tu as une deuxième chance
que tu vas faire tout et n'importe quoi
et là c'est juste qu'en fait je pense
qu'ils voulaient le vendredi arrive pas
lui payer son salaire pour pas jouer ça
doit les saouler et ils ont trouvé enfin
l'occasion pour dire un truc mais c'est
pas très classe quoi surtout pour un mec
classe et 11 ans au club a ramené des
types point d'apparaître aux questions
cooper a obtenu une coupe avec un je
peux finir mieux que ce à quoi tu fait
des adieux classe ton quitté tchèque ce
qu'il se passait j'aime pas ça voilà
donc en février sur la télé j team de
personnes à la rigueur si tu dis oui ils
ont trop grave ce que tu fais tu pas
nuire au club comme ça le club
passionnante à personne mais là
actuellement il a juste rien fait depuis
cinq six mois donc c'est un peu tard
pour réagir de la sorte
voilà j'ai ça en résumé
du coup est-ce que ça ravive le chat sur
ce changement de came as well et ils
sont réalisés ils ont très bien mieux et
c'est très bien ils seront contents
parce que parce que sar est impossible
vous connaissez les goths quitte la mie
câline trop incroyable
je pense que c'est selon l'émir cookies
mieux concevoir c'est pas le même style
du coup via match là parce que cela en
fait ils sont on se voit il son plus dur
mais cela il son genre je souffre ouais
tu peux faire lesquels un week-end ok
beaux cheveux n'étaient pas des cookies
maisons n'ont pas voyagé et j'ai déjà
fait pas mal de pizzas maison j'ai déjà
fait je fais un peu de tous les désirs
j'aime avec son clip non les desserts
n'ont jamais on préfère astro paul quoi
pour choisir quels sont les meilleurs
coups qui entre les deux fois mais il ya
bien une telle tome qui est pas content
du subway devenant et gallas pas si
mauvaise bref en tout cas c'est un
ballet sandwicherie cloud qui tu peux
les prendre ou jamais happart
le cookie mcdo et pas dégueu je ne sais
même pas de ma dose et les cookies
mais j'essaie de faire du fait-maison
tous les trucs industriels bah c'est
très bien non c'est juste que là
exceptionnellement en fait ils font tout
autant les promos j'aurais fonds 3 puis
5 quoi donc là tu te sens obligé
je crois qu'ici ou là quoi payer un
repas gratuit quand même chez beaucoup
promo tu vois les euros qu apparaisse
dans mes yeux tu sais comme genre dans
les dessins animés
le louvre est allé je pense que c'est le
public
voici 8 passes 5 + 1 ça c'est du simple
et sain et donc il y avait évidemment
peu de temps ça va finir sûrement
matches nuls donc sarah qui va être mené
dans la première partie du match mais on
voit pas sarah gagner celle ci non on la
voit pas mais on sait jamais peut-être
aller chercher un petit pion après si
c'est parce que si on touche au
purgatoire g7 non au revoir car à toi tu
voyages
ouais mais quand c'est toujours très mal
très mal le taureau g6 très doux très
nul à bas le arnold c'est un peu chelou
d'harnes et orange était catastrophique
angers 6 ha tiens je parlais danger 5
mais là ce que tu peux voir enfermé
entre ouais ouais mais là force est sans
appel pas me mentir
ouais je sais pas ce que le tournant
coup mystérieux j'ai envie de dire voilà
quand il coupe on passe du cookie alan
exactement astiz joué bon voilà ça
sécurise un peu tout ça walt va te faire
f 4 710 et ce sens mais bon et orange et
trois points ça va pas je sais pas ce
qu'elle veut faire votre voix ça va pas
du tout ce que l'on sait c'est dommage
quoi s'attendre ici c'était pas trop
bien peut être moyen de travailler un
peu sur l'autre aile et la corruption à
5 la cccf pour le blanc pour les noirs
bon manger h saint cloud est possible
mais quand tu veux en fait t'es pas
pressé et quand tu manges h5 immensément
g7 n'ont même temps que ça y est j'ai
pas encore quoi sert à organiser partie
et on sait ce nom mais par contre je
vois qu'elle peut perdre c'est clair non
mais tu te prends tout rejet quatre
échecs loi quand on sait ça avec machin
enfin est ainsi parce qu'elle a
l'expérience et qui va être perdu 1 6 3
défaites tu veux pas perdre trop de
cartons j'ai pu parvenir le ton puis
vois tu peux tenter deux trois trucs au
séjour pour cet anglais n'ont mené 5-1
mais pas pourquoi je vous reviens mais
c'est incompréhensible ces conditions je
sais pas dans cette voie et est de 8,50
bien ok c'est pas moi c'est très bien de
faire mieux je pense
ouais ouais non mais par contre lui et
bon après d'un côté et enfin
c'est vrai que cette dernière partie du
truc c'est sert à rien de faire durer
exprès non plus mais non tu as tu
risques
enfin en fait tu as là nul en poche
c'est clair et la toujours un truc un
certain tu peux perdre tout à gagner tu
peux tenter devants dans le match
général était trop court j'ai cadres qui
avaient loué peut-être alors bon je
pense que celle qu'elle a tissés quoi
j'ai trois jeux prend 1,5
ok - 5 pour dessein croire ces quêtes
normalement mais bon le faire à tours 2
mais bon tu feras tour à cette voie
libre à ses quatre sujets très logique
17 hockey opératoire doit être aidé moi
je frémis au pire depuis chacun pour ben
voilà c'est ça c'est logique de fermer
l'oeil comme ça est-ce qu'il va la jouer
un che sprint car d2 en vue du jeu quoi
barre toi moi je vous parle on est
toujours je suis surpris en fait
voteront jamais qui fait quoi comment
mais j'espère c'est le genre d'histoire
qui l'ont enlevée sont de l'autre côté
os x et c'est bizarre et tout peut se
passer je trouve que c'est vraiment
risqué de la part des blancs de jouer
avec seulement 20 secondes répondu non
tout le monde risquent en fait c'est mon
affaire si si avec 3,7 est bon le
problème c'est que tu fais pas d'âme
comme ça quand même non ça prend des
chèques en h4 pas tomber 3 c'est logique
et puis h4 j'aime pas j'aime pas les
blancs je trouve qu'ils ont beaucoup
trop risqué tu te prends un échec 3-3 va
chaque coup cette pareil hein toute
façon c'est une case tu bouges soin de
toi celle là est peut-être effarant et 7
alors pour maintenant mais torres trop
beau et trop chaud
ouais c'est dur a évoqué sa vie normale
je leur envoyais pas toi vite ou ou
trois sets mais n'importe quoi bon j'ai
pas bon c'est donc en grande finale
c mais ce qui se passe là c'est
incroyable je comprends pas comment on
peut fédérer tu rebondissements mais du
coup ça rebondit vraiment quoi bon pour
éviter de se prendre un chien dame mais
dans le monde tout est possible quand
même auquel le faire c'est pas mal ouais
tu manges et devait gagner normalement
normalement il doit purger bien sport
team là c'est bien
j'aime bien le thème ou cinq bonnes
vieilles soutien prendre âge de l'avenir
vers le hockey bas 2 du coup pourquoi
elle a poussé dirai pourquoi la page
times
non je sais pas si avec soin les adultes
et juste faire mais nous savons la
rochelle elle ollier léché que l'on
mange c'est bien sûr la victoire des
trois échecs tu vas jamais dire oui oui
c'est pas possible de perdre ce à quoi
pas même je pense tu veux jouer pour
gagner pour détroit aura bougé h3t
sayous ou tour des trois tours et ce
trois jours revient sur le fait chaque
et puis on en parle plus on fait nul
quoi mais là où les tours à 7 mais le
truc ça va être quand tu laisses le pion
avancé cette vraiment sur soi ça pue
cncas de dames dans ses options prendre
la valeur et il est chiant quoi donc tu
dois juste l'empêché pas là mais comme
celui-là tu mène au score c'est pas toi
de jouer enfin il resterait une ou deux
parties dans le match et menaient d'un
point tu prends les risques je peux
comprendre la bon il est pas de raison
il peut raison du tout du tout et tu
peux je check et leur disent qu'ils
racontaient sur dan b4 et chaque j'ai
pas aimé qu'l et c3 je pourrais pas
votre parole
c'est très tôt dans la porte une fois
que six sets par l'âge +38 peut-être
ah ouais ouais donc la web ont taillé à
chaque problème si tu m'as qu'ayant des
deux s'est oubliée là par séverine met
la barre haut rose parlera enfin je peux
avec maintenant si tu veux on se
débrouillait bien sont aussi oui ouais
c'est si grave
amesys est très connu à cet amalgame je
connais pas trop j'ai crié des bons
rails par un pion kessy 3g mais pas nul
mais plein deuil et plein de ya plein de
langues différentes et juste doc
deuxième question alors qu'elle sait
trop où le droit est fait et il
connaissait la partie ouais date d'un
procès des caps étaient si les merdias
parc a troqué week et c3 faut bouffer et
lieu quoi d'apprendre un profession
prend je voudrais que ça serait bank
pavel points noirs ça n'a pas été si
bien que ça prenne je te l était pas mal
mais j'ai pas trouvé spécialement mieux
c'était comme qui s'immolent par la voix
la bouche à bouche tu voulais dire quoi
je vois d'un caron b prend lorsqu'il de
l'ordi wade e-services 0,36 ok non je me
serais attendu à ce que non les noirs
saumur et ben non
ok bon c'est pas plus mal à remettre une
clé cette fois la voir et tout savoir
ils sont tombés quatre échecs et le la
muzelle bien grave à menin d'accord
c'était cavalli si si c'est non 26 ans
maman je suis que c'est pas bien pour
les blancs du coup pas fou j'ai deux
mecs lycées trois peut-être oui si pas
compris pourquoi pas qualifier trop
directe web allait oublier
moi je dis oui bon je les fous j'ai deux
que quatre grands fous je fais mc2 tu
repars mais en fait non tadam dès 4h les
vrais sa balle oublié de jouer vite fait
de rappeler à priori fou g2a semble
naturel poids 1
si tu connais pas le truc que tu fasses
corvée normand et c'était pas censé
reprendre deux fois dans cette position
là en fait savoir c'est juste que
qu'elle sait si c'est la faulx vraiment
qu'ils jouent qu'à laisser 3 contre
cavale
le 4 mai du coup en fait il ya cette
même position avec justement avec le
fond j'ai 2 et l'a donc quand les noirs
fonds propres en d2 à ce moment là je
pense aussi à reprendre du quart et demi
vont appris sur moi que si tu travailles
la variante d'un procès c'est bon aussi
avec ya juste ce qui est de même des
variantes avec sacrifice de pions quel
est des deux est un peu tu laisses tu
laisses ce pion c4 mais la dame est un
peu mal placé en fin il ya pas mal de
parle de trucs dans cette ouverture ça
c'est riche mais mais bon à merci bon ok
donc
donc voilà il ya eu lieu la pose là et
de la pause qui revient à l'ecoute web à
deux doigts cette affaire mais ouais ça
peut-être je suis un peu stressé parce
qu'elles savent c'est le gagnera
peut-être qu'il ya moyen de ce qui était
vrai grosse finale alors ouais ya un
enjeu c'est pas une partie point bas un
match plein et alex goude bossard qui
tient le choc
j'étais un peu inquiet par un moment mal
je trouve que poil en souffrance mais
écoute de deux ça va tout va bien et tu
tes joueurs c'est certain donc on va
voir pose aux fraîcheurs ouais moi aussi
j'aime j'aimerais faire un thé je pense
pas ça me pose chaleur ça j'aime bien
l'été ça cool ouais c'est une c'est une
belle période de l'année
nathan gerbe et la pub la 2e journée
puis la pub
ouais allez tout de suite les gars
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
et
eh bien
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
et
je
[Musique]
et bientôt de retour de retour et c'est
déjà reparti il a vu les premiers coups
à moi vers défi d'éviter ces espagnols
auraient ouais c'est possible sur ces
trois mois ce succès possible c'est
intéressant ça va ce monsieur qui est un
sujet secours entre les matches voilà
pleut déjà dit qu'il y aurait des textos
mais elle n'a pas tout lu donc on sait
pas tout ce qu'elle a lu mes livres 2 3
trucs à ses biens
gros avantage noire l'a apparemment
c'est quoi le trou 2005
je ne sais pas allez censés connaître
henri le g5 c'est quoi le coup non pas
page l'espace riquet les guichetiers
sont offert un peu raté complètement
frise moi je frise pas ces 21èmes jeux
de plus
ouais c'est pas l'ordi disait en tout
cas gros avantage +1 21 c'est quand même
un gros avantage dans un mois du coup
c'est quoi le projet tester rock de
cross et c'est là
cette banque c'est rock mais bascule
noir à côté ça va pas ça que j'avais
envie de rock et pour ça je faisais des
dessins qui convoque dans quel ordre
après écoute salaire de l'étoile vents
et marées sa défense elle assistait la
prépare ok ça joue l'entraîneur aux
aguets ils surveillent les matches il
accepte jumelles le bord de la pelouse
il voit les efforts de reclassement ou
pas de la joueuse
la joueuse iranienne pour le prochain
match
je relis toi pourquoi pas remarquer
c'est une super ambiance jeu comme ça
bon alors aux questions qu'elles
révèlent cavaliers en 5
c'est ça son idée cela dit ce que des
f-5 sinisé s'attaque aux chouettes avec
les clubs négocient à l'air super bien
bas salaires je sais c'est limite
finalement il ya eu un truc et regardez
ce qu'est un 5-2 f5
enfin bref 5e 52.44 je pensais pas mais
se perd si la fed y ait un effet direct
et j'ai passé de 9,5 était si fort de
passer le coup le temps en retard mais
je dis grand combat 24.4 capte un truc -
qui est peut-être plus percutant quoi
reste à voir à savoir bon sens se joue à
fond nero qui dit que ces quatre maisons
en pet aussi captivante établi ce truc
complètement s'élevant au dessus de tous
bêtes format c'est trop long sur le
match soit vous apprendront ils
changeront bord sont peut rien faire
pour autant alors kg 4 ok
tf1 on écoute ce elle s'accroche avec
les blancs ce parti a fait un
impressionnant mais la bienvenue de cars
2 5l blindes apex milliards afin qu'ils
défendraient ch devenir le 3 et le sacré
ok cowboy blanc de chance ça serait ok
alors que ça avait l'air mal tourné là
tout d'un coup il ya ça joue bon pas tu
peux refaire du tour et puis tu prends
le béton roy qui a aidé six des petits
plans comme ça mais bon les blancs et on
se place et aussi quelques 3 ça va
arriver
je crois que ça va vous faire cg3 j'aime
moins chaud et des autres ouais
peut-être que ça va venir évoquer 25
secondes c'est ce qu'aime temps de jeu
c'est clair c'est tendu elle a été un
peu trop lente effectivement que à la
clémence hier d'un petit rajout de temps
ça peut le faire et rieuse toute assez
vite je me tais tour sur les colonels
acquiescé à troquer mon honneur est
absent mais j'ai pas vraiment l'air
aussi sexy chevalement ça me passe est
la bonne case tu peux appuyer ses 5e
jeux d'hiver f4 tu faire des trucs je
sais pas mais c'est un feeling je n'ai
pas calculé pour dire non et la date un
peu
simplement j'ai complètement parce qu'il
ya ces quatre qui va arriver en fermant
tu vas faire ceci si elle va prendre à
l'apprendre la colonne sait et c'est ça
la différence et blanc qui ont été les
premiers à frapper la tour des dames b33
des coûts chiant dame b3 une double
attaque s'attaque 17 sa taille ou 4 donc
ouais elle n'a pas et c'est dommage
parce que là vraiment une maîtrise et
bien la partie la position hors dom
maître à jouer c'est la fameuse double
attaque des cinq corps constitués pour
quatre peut-être je pense qu'il a en
tout cas la prise si vite way aller
bouffer quatre peut-être maintenant
voilà elle a fait ça c'est le problème
dans ce cas très bon ça va se voir à la
récupération pour moi je pense c'est
obligé mais en tout cas c'est fait
tous répondent sueur mais le bouge james
et 7 elle va rentrer à la paire pour le
roi noir laqué on a très peur mais bon
allez set où là ou là ou là là là qu'est
ce qui se passa aux aubades à 8 mai
contre attaque pour des deux équipes un
excellent album g4 trouvé par ça
excellent un excellent bas et donc j'ai
trois tours et matt barre des 4 bon
c'est pas tout seul elle panique trop
quoi lui seconde c'est beaucoup et une
seconde de rajouter un vrai jeu trop
vite
non mais tu peux tu vraiment passé
quatre secondes sur un coussin
bon bah elle savait pas qui était
gagnante harry bhl a donc j'ai trahi et
de machins qu'elle allait faire ça c'est
pas si mal à se regarder ce qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on devait faire long h3
vas-y d'amd 4h 3 aurait donc d'alger
trop mature et dont le père que soit
leur âge 34
ah mais oui bien sûr pourquoi je crois
avec dam des quatre tours achats machin
tu dois tu dois terminer les blancs et
oui mais surtout quand j'étais assez
dommage c'était oui c'est bien joué
c'était bien je n y croyais et mimée par
fait pas bon ces battues saurai comment
elle est vraiment mal et puis à nouveau
deux tours ses quatre enfants dès 4
machin mais ok alors alerté b3 et la
d'améliorer lé souvent plus d'un bébé
gadret chaque et compagnie ailleurs voir
on va voir les pubs l'histoire du
cabillaud 4 des 6 e 5 7 le plan des
genres j'imagine fou j'ai de jouer eux
cinq envoyé petit rock je pense une b3
elle n'a pas inventé
d'accord c'était amélioration de ses
bourgoin diankov numérique ok bah moi je
comprends c'est que tu as plus de plus
les 80
et aucune structure que j'aime plutôt
bien pour les blancs en général 100 g
pas en fait c'est objectivement c'est
mieux mais j'aime bien l'avant poste en
dessin avant-postes yassif est dans la
place c'est pas ça existe depuis
longtemps le concept d'avant-postes oui
hein c'est un le cas et des sacs dans
bad boys et ça c'est une case sur une
colonne s'est ouverte devant le but
adverse est en fait le cahier là bas il
est chiant parce que si tu le beauf les
blancs panne du pion et du coup tu va
transférer attaque sur place et 7 soit
les larves de la pâte pour ces 6 et ça
affaiblit le pion des six dans tous les
cas tu vas supporter un truc chiant et
si tu veux te l'air en destin on va
juste il est là il est bien placé et il
contrôle près de 15 donc pour ces
raisons là c'est pas mal et je trouve
c'est toujours plus agréable jeu pour
les blancs c'est quoi la en double
simplement on pourra n'a pas trop aride
pour la dame non moi j'ai pas trop envie
d'en face tu peux changer la structure
avec les noirs du coup ça va d'ailleurs
elle n'a pas changé mais il faut coller
un petit pccistes sortons fou et une
bastaque écoute qui avait battu jouault
tu veux ou trois je pense à mon quand
même il dit très bien le rôle de nature
à 1 bat davantage l'espace de trois tu
veux trop qu'ayant des 5
mais bon après - ja pièces plus les
noirs ça va parce que tu as un jardin un
défaut de des spurs on va dire donc
quand à lantages d'espacejeux pas trop
changer les pièces et vice versa moyen
de pièces - à l'espace se voir à mon gré
tel match on a su avoir puis à gagner
comme touriste à louis effectivement
c'est très beau match
beau match c'est réussi 5 soja vers la
partie c'était chaud ouais
et oui fait un arrêt qui aurait gagné
aucun tournoi c'est un peu surprenant
puisque de ba sur le clavier comme ça la
favorite mais de la concurrence en face
ok bon toujours palpable ans je pense
c'est votre objectif en plus ou moins
égales passer cette faible n'a qu' une
faiblesse qui sait combien s'interroge
cette rencontre du coup juste on rend
des 8 7 a besoin tu dois y arriver quoi
pendant ouais t'as bien clément
parce que pour ces 4 et blesse tu peux
pas vous c b6 pascal en tout cas tu te
prendre ouais tu perds un piège est
partout moi je pensais à tour ces quatre
de baser que sur toro ça tu peux le
faire peut-être eu 4 mégabits le poulet
avec donald et des fourrages 3 c'était
peut-être une option aussi quoi et la 4g
à partir à tout à fait pourquoi pas tous
d'ailleurs tu fais a4 a5 un jour moi tu
va échanger le truc sa mère bien fou des
êtres si tu prends pions ouais j'ai
montré 517 enfilade et autour mais du
coup c'est qu'on va c'était une bonne
ressource défensif k-way j'imagine que à
4 c'était vraiment bien pour le moment
mais ça veut dire cool
en tout cas j'ai koné moussa touré c'est
la pression là à 4 rêve écoute elle a
trouvé qu'elle recevrait coiffeur bon
puis on prend tour à sept contre oui
obtient printemps ces quatre kiosques
ouais pourquoi tu fixes possible pris ce
prix-là ramener son fou peut-être un f1
eux deux je garde un oeil sur les deux
pions bon c'est mieux j'aime bien les
blanchir son nom mais torres et ses
vagues
ouais non mais là en contrôle celle qui
joue pour l'avantagé de permettre à tous
rendez cas tu t'en fous touche à rien y
à le prendre h 4 tu prends cela très
bien aimé tu t'améliores touche au roi
déjà peut-être tu peux essayer
d'améliorer verte des quatre mais
s'attend à être pas du fait des petits
coups sur la tête ça a l'air pas qu'on
attend juste un petit chien bien après
tu frappes wave 3 tu pars soir après une
décision
ouais ils vont le faire j'ai quatre
rassemblements bah tant mieux donc ça
devenait trop sur blanche neige at-on
fondé 3g pas je sais ce trajet mais j'ai
envie qu'ils améliorent en fait tous les
toits et bien c'est jack méthane à nadia
sainty faible que tu t'es mis bien
genre là maintenant améliorer des pièces
tranquillement quoi jean papillon c'est
quand même pas si mal mais j'aurais bien
aimé qui passe ce contact jestin cachia
tu peux l'enlever sans l'être soi le
fait j'ai quatre métiers entourage 7 qui
était complètement à la ramasse quoi et
bien sûr ta grâce et jeu très très bien
c'est sûr par contre le désavantagera se
structurent pions mais clémence
totalement pourra planter un g4 s'est
échangé tour ou quoi voir le bon côté
des choses aussi tu laisses pas la torah
battu très active était là puis on prend
un ton plus on peut c'est donc pas mal
je me suis alors venir défendre
van damme purement arcade du coup le
brestois s'est passé pour extra ouais je
pense que ça peut être quatre pas battus
bloc ou essayer de faire du roi 17 tours
j'ai vite elle doit faire je pense leur
part de 70 j'ai vu de cette orbite c'est
quand même un peu relou calculé auquel
est obligé de faire ça tout rachat en ce
qu'elle reviendra le pion tourner un
pion ou la whey pour un soir des vies 3
bougez tour à lui et à le faire roche 4
3 au tour à charge et tu te travaille au
corps avec les blancs
comment on va chercher comment on passe
le temps en fait non c'est passé beige
éclairent un narcissique
c'est malheureux roche 4 ok mais si tu
prends un chien et ce qui est grave si
je retourne tu veux juste passer le roi
c'est ça
ouais c'est pas parce que le plus bref
il est très chiant gentil n'arrive donc
prendre le retour à 500 mètres à fond
quoi bon tant qu'apple a pu prendre des
cinq régions ouest et pas si con au fn
échec laquelle a raté torje 3
peut-être mais je pense qu'elle doit
tenter maladie j'allais dire peut-être
tenté à leur tour à schwyz
mais c'est en prend à sept tours à 7 tu
prends un ep six dates et nul ne le sait
pas mais parce que tu cliques et tu veux
pas tu t'accroches arrivera en fait non
tu peux rien fait en beauté taureaux
engagés les frères frank et à demain
c'était bon mais je vais il manquait pas
grand chose pour la convertir cela fait
dire quant à peu de temps la pendule
mais aïe ça veut dire c'est sûr ça va
venir boire
ok du coup changement d'ouverture de
chez screen est là sont-ils après pat
cornetto way matuidi toi je croyais je
dirai ce que je pense aux siens pour h
et on achète toi cet échec je reprends
ici statues avaient passé leurs adverses
profession 8e beaucoup de choses sympas
ok donc bon c'est cette ouverture la
sorte je peux voir une sorte de fichier
noise sont italiennes on sait pas trop
là-dessus d'appréciation est-ce que tu
prends ce pur ça doit exister et je sais
pas je connais pas des 5 c sur que
alléger ses dribbles et trucks band as
tu prends le demain quoi toi qui prends
moi je répondu qu à valmy
ouais et du fou après
tombé du débat je répondrai donc je veux
pas trop de tirs en tout cas elle a
l'air de connaître avec sandra gauthier
donc c'était peut-être pas la banane
obligés d'aller vingt sept ouvertures en
acier s'est trompé d'heures de cours par
mois donc après la joie ning jeune link
fin y lire que alexandra tuvalu a joué
la petite variante une sorte de
viennoise la rixe et 4,3 machin avec les
north à plusieurs c'est top je pouvais 4
il est correct je peux aussi jouer
callas 5 et les bouffer le foot tu peux
jouer
j'ai plein de trucs mais mais là y'a
rien d'horrible
mais c'est juste qu'en fait je pense
être un plus pour les lampes ce que tu
as la paire de chou et que ça joue mais
en fait objectivement et puis non non ça
pète trop grave mais je préférerais
jouer saint clément des correcteurs et
là il reste hires 2038 d'un point sur 3
puis ça ok normalement c'est le tambour
quatre parties en tout elles m'ont fait
qu de l'âge après deux nuls en tout cas
très serré comme match très serré sahara
qui se défend très bien d'habitude
toutes les demies que je l'avais joué
assez mal tel niveau là d'un coup ouais
parce qu'elle se chauffer chaque l'a pas
trop jeu d'échecs récemment aussi donc
le katla leucate salaires pas qu'on ait
quatre albums phares nul j'ai oublié
c'était très bien
j'ai trop pu l'être encore 4 du tout
aller à la paix tant pis on passait nos
partys pas grave c'est bien aller faire
4-4 mais n'ont que faire du bien mais tu
attends je pense qu'alexandre l'affirmé
le site a pas ses parts en état d'âme
non plus pas peut-être à ne pas faire
hamilton joue sajou adam a dû bouger là
je suis passionné j'aime cette dépense
et les pions parce que dire non mais en
fait si tu veux jouer ça c'est bientôt
avoir perdu le seul problème mais
facteurs celle qui fait quoi
mais en fait pas juste qu'il veut à la
partie va nous réserver des surprises
objectivement auquel donne à 5 doit
purger trois cavaliers f4 je n'ai pas
été échangés sur abc c'est soit ça part
de là je vais faire un pas pour gagner
global corporate north a alors ça va je
préfère nul c'est avec ces mots oui mais
après à force tu peux le temps voilà
qu'on tricot cie s'est fait n'importe
quoi pour gagner n'est pas bien tu te
refais la structure j'ai mon père oui on
va prendre en charge et 5 g 5 master
classes y en ait qui ont doublé
qui est telle que l'on peut prendre la
tour 4 et on va voir ses retours des 4e
tour des quatre spéciales à choix du
point 4 face à la tour b 5
mais voilà j'aime pas ça j'aime pas ça
je sens que c'est en train de tourner
j'aime pas ça bon c'est pas non plus la
fin du monde mais salue cento russe ne
fait pas ça doit les enfants qui est
plus simple avant mais c'est pas grave
mais qui est en train de prendre ces
sept apprentis échec et on va chercher
cela probablement pour poser le faire
trop de crème sel en vie mais pourquoi
pas ma tasse et je vois pas masquer ou à
du bois cd28 là par contre chez soi ce
que l'afld reproche aux bataves
plusieurs options mais messi besson à
qui va devoir se décider alors pu faire
bref trois peut-être forte qu'elle a
toujours empêché tours de magie qui est
meilleur un final sahara je sais pas ce
qu'a dit je pensais les meilleures
finales mais qu'il sera ok
jardi kosteniuk mouais ça mais eric
besson le match 3-6 était pas au chant
ménages plus d'expérience était une
école rue tu dis bon se doit les ouais
mais là aujourd'hui je sais papa du âge
peut être faire de son style de jeu je
sais pas moi je pense qu'elle veut faire
tordre et 2 ce soit pareil nous que
toronto 6-1 probablement ouais je me
disais ça ça serait pareil j'ai des
souvenirs de finale bizarrement traitez
moi j'ai pas trop venir mais ouais
aujourd'hui incertaine comme dit par
rexel ou à laisser faire dame mais c'est
qu'il n'en a l'air bien
si sur ce cas ok bon à chaque truc
normal un comptable de magna tout
pourrait changer les pions et 6 tu
défense puis tu peux m'appeler sur mon
corps
la boucle est bon ça tend vers nul à
cinq secondes quatre siècles et blanc
normalement ça devrait aller retour à
huis clos ce parcours à fond c'est les
bleus qui prennent des risques là c'est
sûr ça va être très compliqué est ce que
tu es sprint va réussir à sauver celle
là je pense que oui ou non elle va
gagner incurable mais ces deux contrats
sont là mais la presse les justes le
théorique mais pendant tout coeur que
peu de temps la pendule des bricoles pas
censé arriver quoi je m'attendais 5 par
exemple
ok mais use les nerfs ont raison de
jouer la taquine pleine bien si tu t'en
fous tu as beau but cette saison de plus
surtout américaines 7 minutes
il reste est le temps pour une partie à
courcelles la gipa et mes proches 4g
moyen de gagner trois coupes et les
renverrait de 5 et 4 pour tenter torje 5
je pense tu le prends encore virage 4 tu
monteras en justicier de saint claud et
voilà c'est exactement ce qu'elle fait à
80 motos temps je t'assure objectivement
c'est nul oui nous sommes ceux des
spéciales très bon droit les bons
sauvages ou un petit moment ce sont les
bons jeux 50 coup par démont classe et
bien je sens aussi sa limite
mios très bien joué surtout pleurons est
en tout mais ça va pas être suffisant
malheureusement j'ai pas mal à toi tu te
fatigues l'adversaire comme ça aussi tu
joues en freeroll il pourrait arriver
mais a dû lui arriver quoi qu'il en soit
inexorablement voilà c'est maintenant
qu'on va faire phildar donc salée finale
pour ce que ce chat c'est vraiment nul
des fois tour est un pion concours ça
gagne c'est à dire toutes les fenêtres
tour un pion sont nulles mais quand le
roi de la défense et devant le pion
comme ça pourrait se passer et ça ça
finit en pâte c'est jusqu'au bout voilà
ok
non mon corps en partie produit mâle
super serré surtout si de france alors
tout puissant
alors il va nous rejoindre je m'appelle
comme je connais cette pente avec fuji
5,6 pas mal d'infos prend ouais c'est
pas trop le choix
ouais soit tu joues ça ça tu joues avec
des pros et s'éprend dessin il ya
quelque chose de plus qui est un truc
important à ça avec les blancs générale
s'est conclue avant de prendre tout le
centre avait que 6 des cinq matches
arrangés que 4 1 jour la pression je
peux à l'expert si on joue sa gnac et
boulogne était noir en boucle les dieux
je connais rien je suis pas non plus
gros mais la 3000e biologie non en fait
il reste encore le bullet après toute
façon on n'est qu'à mi match
duch un match mais parce que les risques
est militante rappelé en a fait
seulement ne s'est pas encore du mali
dont ils sont quoi qu'il se passe dans
cette partie aura au moins trois buts il
y aura dix doublettes rojas trois bulles
est minime
et voila voila nordiste un badge j'ai
pas trop pourquoi ces 3 way
non non non si un prix ce jeu borges
support du prochain prime 3 corruption
je comprends pas pourquoi ils sont votre
qu'à moitié
ba cède -0 vite je sais pas mais ouais
rien sur la question d'un joueur qui a
un potentiel et quesnoy le garde fou
déjà et sa fille et ses 5
c'est une case il gagne quoi la
vainqueure du tournoi et vainqueurs de
tournois gagner 3000 $ russes n'ont que
trop ça mais c'était il ya des prix à
chaque tournoi sur la route quand même
non oui c'est bien possible
moi chaque jour 3000 e ouais je pense
que chaque tournoi mini tournoi chaque
semaine et primé et qu'après tu as un
truc final un petit bonus ma vie
parce que l'argent je veux un mois
d'affilée premier 3000 moi non je pense
quoi certains leur niveau bon écoute
mais là comme ça que philippe hurepel
marque on arrivé là donc clairement là
du jeu il ya des compensations mais chut
ça va ravir jeu pas de trop trois pièces
spéciales pour les blancs qu'il fallait
pas d'autre date
après bon clairement c'est chaud tour 3
je pense va pousser b6 à un moment donné
quand même on menace bcsa sur pandora de
toi pour jordi fera de pour garder cette
menace me garder la pression sur ça
assez mais bon les 6 à 5 pas voir trois
tours à deux si je fais et rock festif
et a5 est ce que est ce que ça te sert à
manger jusqu'à 4-3 au moins bon et là on
sait pas ce qu'elle fait mais je défends
le 4 et les pas trop attaquer pour les
pièces noires les métiers qu'ils font
chier fait soif d'apprendre et en vous
des uns ne me dérange pas
c'est bon on s'est vraiment faisait les
changer d'armé on va le faire du damas a
brisé change
ok bon c'est pas clair tarifs 5 ans ils
ont tous rire c'est quand même tendu
quand même tendu comme position mais le
roi blanc et yves issue un peu creux
ouais c'est clair qu'ils aient des
quatre j'aime bien votre ordi compte pas
jouer a probablement joué je trouve bien
ils sont très zélé il devra peut être
cinq équipes et lancer six plus cher des
trucs b6 pas mal je vais ouvrir alors
oui bien sûr je sais pas dommage qu'on
sort j'aimerais voir ok si je voulais
pages on va en fait c'était robin des
bois 7 et des systèmes qualif cattier
fait genre tu avais plusieurs plusieurs
tournois plusieurs mégatonnes importe
qualifiés vont cesser évidemment hyper
jo fallait finir premier et dans l'est
le solde premièrement dans chaque
tournoi est vrai choix y avait quoi y
avait six tournois un truc comme ça
peut-être
ouais ouais ça fait bon c'était c'est
très compliqué c'était super serré j'en
ai fait un et puis ok le rich ricci
président parmi vous ont permis aux
parents je l'avouer je n'accepte pas ce
que je n'aime pas tout y est pas mieux
mais les tours et vite vont arriver à l
ac ça pue c'est dur la seconde fois
j'ai passé tellement mauvais de
reprendre du fou là je sais pas on pense
au vu de la partie chaud que ce soit
pire ça non mais je sais pas toi c'est
pas et par un coût horrible mais mais
c'est dur jusqu à merveille mais ce
départ est un jeu j'aime pas je sais
même plus à plus en plus n'ont pas ces
chocs
du coup c'est vrai et ses trois échecs
auxquels roi sans valve qui rb5 d'être
contre bush confettis et b3 je sais pas
quel effet tour des trois bons défend
tour la jouer vite et qu elle s'accroche
à ce garçon qui va venir verser 4 on
sait pas enfin c'est pas perdu c'est
juste une salle position un peu chiant
quand mais bon si c'est ok à cinq elle
envoie le pion qui essaient quatre
attaques la toile tour dans l'abat tour
à un peu de nantua ain ille raffoux
détrousser trop attention pas mal ça
évite à 4 bien jouer il va faire que ces
cinq j'imagine mais elle va blindés
après avec du tour des trois quais à
troyes où tour à 12 3 2 voilà plongé de
3 2 et écoute faut encore passer qui n'a
ainsi pas fait
tu vas faire voir deux rois des 3c
carrick kelly bouge on va voir page
robot gagnac là je suis un garçon vient
juste hors fou c'est mieux pour
cavaliers machin vous êtes un le
problème peut-être les normes faire un
pied 5 un moment de péter des pions
monter le roi mais futsal c'est pas très
très gentil avec we may 14 secondes
assez c'est vraiment très très peu moi
je me sentirais très très inconfortable
st-gall feroze 3ème l'impression de tout
ça c'est horrible
ça c'est vraiment parce qu'elle prend du
cavalier peut-être qu'on va prendre les
sagas que la tour pour une méga
fourchette en epci fin de la partie tu
arrives pas elle mêle trop lente pour se
prendre ça pourquoi l'aperçu à chaque
fois c'est s'est rompu sa jambe au bras
au wawel
je les ai pas du tout saisi bas celui
que je viens à 3 vos biens de qualité
mais est-ce qu'on peut pas rendre déjà
un peu je pense qu'on égalise
mais la trop grande faim maintenant que
je sais pas c'est intéressant une
décision pratique intéressante de
costing en tout cas si intéressante ou
[Musique]
l'ordi s'était emballé son coup j'ai pas
pourquoi mais j'ai vu que l'on aura vite
faut faire quand tu veux écoute c'est
chaud je sais même pas s'ils tiennent
pas et noir ça donne juste beaucoup de
ges avec les normes et au d5 c'est
chiant on va tendre à lui annonça
fallait pas laisser le roi ans et kate
faute de nom mais c'est tellement chaud
alors elle s'est tranché fonds mais la
théorie
tu peut pas rattraper les 2 kg en ta
tour et un pls dommage non
ace combat jonage bourg gouttes des
points de retard c'est que les fils de
qualité non c'est pas con mais je
n'étais pas du tout fait les frais 4 sur
mon mail times ait droit à 100 avant
même que je sais pas mais mais savez
vous qu est il est intéressant mais c
est ce qu on peut par an c'est pas toi
tu vas perdre celui-là tu étais en quoi
3,8 c'est quoi le problème
quand ça maintenant
à toi web on va prendre ses cinq pieds
après j'arrête c'est juste on évite
juste la fourchette en c4 je comprends
c'est ça que moi ces cinq tours pour ces
trois parus en temps des cas 3 bougez
t'en prends des sens et je vais prendre
à trois ouais ouais nul ne sait pas
jouer comme je sais pas je trouvais ça
est risqué pour les mains mettais plein
est ok là haut tout reprend machin ne
décroche pas sur le bras droit vente une
grosse décision sinon peut-être tomber
si je pensais pour couper loi je sais
pas je trouvais ça bien pour les bleus
mais peut-être que je me trompe mais je
suis pas sûr juste pas pu prendre à
trois en fait monsieur si oui bien sûr
tu peux prendre un train non mais rusé
que le renoir arrive à mes amis l'a
retrouvée tout cas je regarde des
voitures bessette c'est bien autour des
deux salaires des droits probable peur
mais je tombais 7 c'est bien peu rivaux
si c'est toujours un peu près à chaque
et oui tu fais des trucs avec tetro se
fait pas grand chose mais moi pas tu
sois gay tant que dans peu de temps a
répondu à 10h ccir sociaux non mais du
goûte au tour 2 à 3 celle ci ouais c'est
autant un gareth bale mais nulle autre
chose
je serais vraiment partie du monde ok on
touche là lens était tombée cet après
françois qu'on gagnerait mais c'était
quand même la meilleure décision et 3 3
ça me semble être l'option safe bon
copain à l'otan le souffleur c'était
sérieux
c'est pas si mal du mal à sketches grand
chose en peluche et pato rodez est ce
que tu risques un truc non pas vraiment
parce qu'à chaque fois ci
défendus mais en fait dans la finale
juste tu peux avoir le truc là ben moi
je serai plus là le roi reine sans
couronne en a les traits bussy et non
plus prévu chez voilà le pendule y
éjecté de sa vie il en fait j'ai lu un
truc sur le pont du globe dont tu fais
le roi qui regardent pas - et dont
j'avais ce moment tête qui allait pas
excessivement fier je m'excuse et le
beau temps à 3 doit perdre pour les pour
les noirs mais c'est un piège pour que
ç'a permis parce que tu es tu content ce
soir 5 3 et 6 mois pas de chance j'ai
regardé célèbres bûchers les gars celle
qui joue a perdu il se trouve ce genre
de jeu malin ils ont pas tenu des
attentes
on se range les deux peut-être tu fais 5
et que c'est une rue sommes ok m'hamed
munger s'est pas bien passé pour servat
la cdm watch pesqué d'admirateurs dans
le match on s'accroche très bien même
cette partie keeper écoute se joue à la
fin ça je vois pas les choses plus de
temps plus le temps est ok of war non
allez motive la cua ouais il a dû on met
sa came à fond qu'elle était dedans mais
faire on est tous bords sarala jeudi
dans son collège je vais maracas un peu
la casse d'ailleurs c'est aussi aux
couleurs j'ai dirigé l'irak non pardon
c'est aussi aux colères de l'iran un peu
ouais voilà c'était pour l'inde pour
lire ans pour tout le monde a les bombes
à la limite il es qui pour alexandra
bingerville maracas production
industrielle
le chat sénart comble du match avec lui
tu vas te faire mal pas de chance c'est
comme ça c'est la dictature et si de
façon sh-awd bondé mais bien l affaire
du russe dans la tronche ou davaï ouais
ok battant qui hein c'est pas fini c'est
qu un point retard un bullet ça se
présente comme ça quoique aller à
nous-mêmes réussir c'est à dire en vue
donc
c'est chaud là c'est le cyrillique un
métier ça ressemble un peu en russie
tandis qu'il en sens inverse
bon en même temps chacun 35 ça tombe
bien que tu ai demandé 30 secondes
bâlois dans les starting blocks du coup
ça faut pas perdre la prochaine
ça c'est hyper important moralement way
lors les noirs sa lettre 4 je pense
qu'elle va lui rejouer sa viennoise et
moi je vais vite et bien voilà c'est bon
ça une variante avec air one
je pense que le jeu tout est jouable
c'est du but l'attaquant russe qu'elle
joue un système bonne maîtrise des trucs
fois qu'elle se fasse taper
réfléchissent ok je vais faire je sais
pas je 4,5 tout le temps le fait tout le
temps et d un style dont l'ouverture
même que je connais devant suarez 3 e 2
allez c'est parti
oui 4,5 à l'if3 ok bon c'est très
spécial je vais m'en fous ces quatre
italiennes pouces et 5
bk bima c'est alexandra qu'ils assurent
ça va être chaud du biovein
j'espère que connaît parce que c'est
très très chaud ouais t dmb 3 à partir
des coûts commence à 4,7 mais bon
c'était hyper populaire une centaine
d'années genre de variantes
moralement ça va mais c'est même pas si
c'est pas si pourri quoi surtout pour du
bullet jeu alors oui pour des villes et
imaginaire mais moqué sport à fabas tuân
on avec quoi bon long qui en fait ça va
quoi passer une galerie peut jouer est
alors de connaître un peu les plantes
les blancs elle te pouvoir la structure
leader à quoi elle va
elle envoie ce n'est pas trop grave en
souffrance mais rien de si grave mais
prennent ce qu'ils jouent très très vite
inquiété et a préparé son affaire et
joue extrêmement bien là tu veux faire
quoi tu va doubler sur la ctu vois tu
veux aller par là mais franchement à
coeur c'est bien elle a survécu
elle a survécu elle s'est pris des fêtes
surtout elle s'est battue elle tend son
point de plus
alors pourquoi pas pourquoi pas tout
peut tout voir avec tours 8 gens c'est
ça ton putsch a fait des coups quoi mais
joue vite au paf pas plomber les gars on
y va très bien tous russes à l'exception
des gares ça va fatigue a rien de grave
wen grave du tout et même la galice est
sorti sur pc on se doit d'être le tout à
droite et à gauche alors que 17 défend
tous allés propres en flammes attaque
attention mesdames h4 j'imagine voilà
attaque 4 kg 3 c'est fou 17 on imagine
dames c'est se confronter à damas a
touché pas de quoi les cages qatada vers
l'avant elle se bat à fond pourquoi pas
un couteau et est ce qu'il ya des fois
soit qui peuvent arriver
t'es pas y aller ce 3 comme quoi ça peut
un jour là c'est pas bien mais tu as tu
fait si ce soit surtout bleus ne suis
pas folle soir ils sont fait pincer qui
est pas le meilleur est bon pour du
bullet contrôle simple d'un point ça
c'est un peu court c'est un peu comme un
peu quoi sert il y aura quatre des
maîtres du couloir d'être machin wade
mg5 c'est dommage
c'est dommage mais non mais là ça va pas
parce qu'il accueille la f1 au pire
ouais bon ben ok fera pas bon le swing
déjà le string 2h05 47 la fois il faut
gagner des parties ouais surtout celle
là il reste à portée de tir
allez on a eu beaucoup ab3 second à la
peau bleue mais en fait c'est un ordre
de quoi c'est bizarre je pense que je
pense qu'il faut je veux qu'elle ait
cessé avant de prendre des deux nous
sommes au bon morceau de choix alors
comme chaussures faites mais ouais
sémalens b3 à b2 je comprends qu'on se
défende et 4 des français 4c font tous
les pions et en plus affaibli car oui
voilà c'est ça c'est l'entraînement
complet comme planque
ça fait trop de choses on a un coût
c'est forcément un bon coup un truc
comme ça
oui bien sûr c'est très tendance pour ça
que je disais qu'elle lors des coudes et
noir s'étaient pas forcément au top de
bain battant l'egypte à l'estonienne ça
va pas tout son coeur à les pousse des
fonds cela quoi on veut du le swing ont
vu un match de pour la fin quoi la
qualité à l'est ne sais pas ce que tu
dois faire mes études à le faire vite
ouais c'est la conviction quand je vois
la tour eiffe toiture différence tous
les sens sont fous ces tissus pipou et
ben ali guaka quoi on regarde même pas
ce qui se passe on plus chez toi toi
même tu auras 3 ce qui est intéressant
avec id froid toujours c'est pas faire
un bon coiffeur truc aller s'amuser tour
en moins c'est pas ça pour couper le
citron quoi warrick toit ni va aller
trancher au couteau jouer à la gorgue
aux gars que tu vas partir après et
entache d'espacé bien même ces trois
défenses pire défense pian et 4
s'intéressant aussi chez babeth 24 ans
tu vois j'ai eu quatre jours
rochât prostitution voilà rachat tu vois
la connexion ne sais pas c'est pas
simple c'est pas simple c'est sûr c'est
sûr mais non elle se trompe l'oeil
j'attaque sens bien je taxé fiant à
l'est
aux abois leur disant mal tu pourras
aller allez bon écoute
aïe aïe aïe ça tombe mal ça tombe très
mal pour la joueuse et ça c'est à dire
dans ce palais vu l'arrivée du cannabis
oui très bien la justice double attaque
bon il y avait des couilles vous n'êtes
s'accroche et le sacre à la tête dû
faire un tour c'est 3 que faire très mal
au revoir bondissant bâle iii etc 3
dépensé 4 j'ai pas vu mais bon je sais
pas ce que j'ai pas vu allez prends des
six jeux séparés dos à ces durs sans
mater ou paquet prend décision fait 5
hockey et hautbois et coûte trois
plantes en bullet voilà c'est ce à quoi
la chercher cette qualif en bullet
avance d'un match ultra serré du match
et arracher une perf est ok dommage
dommage dommage voilà car ça fait trop
il reste encore des parties mais c'est
plus pour un pour le dit ce sont ces une
cadence en temps un coude à l'ail
dès lors après le temps de revenir
quatre minutes il reste quatre minutes
c'est fini bongo fille alexandra perd sa
collection ont relancé par journée 5e
fois mais c'est un petit des trois comme
l a fait j'aimais bien cette ouverture
ouais j'avais une super relation n'avait
le fameux grotte qui était possible à un
moment quoi meiway qu'alexis b5
boitaclous 2 c'était plus fort mais
bougeais pas bien tant les cailloux 5
peut-être le 3
serhat attaque moi aussi rappelé aux
marchés passés chose même f4 à partir
dans votre perte des tracts avec la main
que ces quatre éléments j'imagine
partout ça envoie c'est bien pour lui
cette ouverture
les free 4 kg 6 au québec où ça n'allait
pas trop mal c'est bien ça va la gagner
vite ce parti fait la gueule ni vite
pour avoir mené temps de remonter après
aller mais j'ai peur que vraiment il est
très très très très vite pour gagner
trois fois la gagne est extrêmement vite
bon ben ali et non vraiment c'est final
pièce d'opus pièce de plus à tout va
bien tout va bien bon centre marc
lescoute va s'échanger mais vrai le
temps a passé et ont offert une autre
mais pas deux tout à l'heure c'est le
problème c'est un manque de temps le
chanteur en pls c'est dommage parce que
je trouve que pour coup et là vraiment
c'est un meilleur la chance que mon
match aujourd'hui
vraiment je sorti son match mais bon
c'est un film à des noms et non qu'est
née des cinq tours prend ses caténaires
à pernes pièce quelle horreur aïe aïe
aïe
quelle horreur dire à dur dur mais
écoute
[Musique]
ouais voilà aujourd'hui franchement du
match pour que la femme bien meilleur
match que ce que j'avais vu sur les
autres demis ouais mais j'crois
troisième place dommage qu'ils aient pas
encore un mois de compétition par ci
déclarait notamment des correcteurs ce
match pour le gagner la justice non plus
sans jouer à grand chose c'est sûr c'est
pas un vol cessières de ses réponses ou
wells était l'arrière star du peloton
thibaut pinot la chaîne il a déjà son tu
vois il y aura même pas tous partis de
quatrième parti souhaite être une partie
très longue
ça a duré 80 coup je sais pas quoi mais
en faisant à perdre mais écoute finale
qui est sympa entre donc alexandra et
les connais roues et je vois sera moins
favorite sur le papier pas de normes
internes mais juste motivé soit parce
que tout jeu peut-être la gagne enfin
qualif mais ça aura quand même elle a
battu un hameau étude complète sera pour
pour ailleurs pour révéler en fait est
du bellay damouzy choqué le internet
c'est pas son truc non et oui je plains
soit bien plus vite et partie belge a
tous beaucoup mix favorable mais surtout
en bullet je pense qu'elle est en télé
ce total le betis otto witte
ouais mais oui et c'est qu'effectivement
ça a l'air intéressant dans l'ouverture
bref une amitié c est la fin j'ai passé
mon nom c'est l'autre ou pas est restée
cinq secondes
ok 5 secondes pendant une dernière alors
une dernière fois
vous proposez lui lance via le droit au
dessus oui c'est clair
à pourquoi ils sont dix huit façons le
match a finalement leur maturation des
primaires oui le fameux finale dimanche
et au bac ce point toujours bon quand on
souhaite qu'ils bossent des arguments
qui se voit que tout le monde il est
beau il est quoi la grande finale
séquencé lundi si la semaine prochaine
on se bat la grande finale
ben écoute je vais voir le programme
d'ailleurs je peux aller le voir ici la
grande finale c'est un de tes news lundi
voilà lundi la grande finale donc conejo
et s'est qualifié web avec windows ou
c'est pas facile quoi koné s'est
qualifié face à huy fans et clients car
oui mais c'est pas mal un huitième
finale aussi elle a joué deux heures
d'un possible c'était gorria dirais
enfin je comprends cela le jeune russe
ouais donc la paye des appareils ont
penalty est allé chercher ce finalement
c'est certain mais voilà donc en tête
toujours du classement
babouche et nina et guo linna queens est
avec 112 points
donc si jamais elle gagne la pierre elle
marque à 12 points de plus avoir 24 ans
il sera qualifié clair ouais c'est pas
pour ça sera le départage entre guînes à
ses mails
après le succès qu'elle saura pas gagné
un seul gagne pas d'erreur sera pas
gâchée voilà ça et là de son destin
entre les mains
ouais autres les pieds montre les bras
et mais voilà donc cette fois sympa à
suivre parce que il ya également jeudi
mme khalip groupe y en à g et puis voilà
lundi la grande finale et avoir du
suspense enfin un match pour lequel on
est peu de chose va probablement vibrer
un gros enjeu donc fallu meech et
alexandra qu'à gagner et dans le premier
match que je suis aujourd'hui c'est une
pige généraux qui a battu we fans donc
nous voilà en tout cas c'était très
sympa c'était très sympa c'est comme
temps avec toi favé merci au chat merci
à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis c'était
existait du temps
moi je vous dis à bientôt ouais voilà
c'est vraiment ni pas n'ai pas essayé
comme angers après on sait jamais merci
spice guy pas trop quand on fait ça et
j'aime être à l écueil dit merci pour le
son ah voilà
non merci de nous avoir suivis et puis
et puis à très bientôt des tentes en
essais 14h30 moment demain enfin comme
tous les jours je m'amuse et d'y manger
un truc devant nancy dimanche
normalement ce qui leur vaut 30 pour à
checker d'influencé 14h30
voilà donc ouais en fait ma petite pub
pour mama chesnais
slash en direct et petite pub pour le
twitteuse de fabien il est plus actif
plus souvent je suis suivi l'est c'est
toujours très pertinent ce que j'ai ça
qui est important surtout voilà merci à
tous et tatiana me salée